Staat modernisiert werden die Union
befürwortet zwar die Anhebung der Hartz
IV-Regelsätze lehnt aber das Bürgergeld
ab weil dadurch quasi ein garantiertes
Grundeinkommen ohne Arbeit eingeführt
wurde soweit die Ausgangslage er hat
schärfer im Deutschen Bundestag also die
politische Gemengelage ist also klar die
Ampel will das Bürgergeld die Uhr Union
nicht wie könnte denn ein Kompromiss
aussehen was hört man denn
das gucken wir uns gleich mal genauer an
ich würde gerne noch mal verweisen am
Anfang darauf dass das hier durchaus die
Woche sozialpolitischer und
arbeitsmarktpolitischer Entscheidungen
ist neben anderen wichtigen natürlich
die wir auch nicht unterschlagen wollen
aber wenn man mal genauer hinguckt es
geht ja nicht nur um das Bürgergeld in
dieser Woche am Mittwoch hat die
Koalition das Wohngeld plusgesetz
eingebracht es wird heute an diesem
Donnerstag unter anderem noch gehen um
den sogenannten dezemberabschlag der ja
auch zumindest sozialpolitische Aspekte
hat außerdem die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes und ein Inflationsausgleich
soll geschaffen werden für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger also jede Menge
Themen auf diesem Sektor in diesen Tagen
hier im Deutschen Bundestag und die
ganzen Gemengelage beim Bürgergeld Hans
Werner füttgau haben sie gerade schon
hinreichend erklärt 68 Minuten Debatte
wird zwar gleich geben im Plenum und wir
haben noch 14 Minuten Vorbereitung auf
diese Debatte und ich freue mich dass
bei uns sind Dagmar Schmidt die
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
SPD-Fraktion und Hermann Gröhe ist der
der dieselbe Funktion in der
Unionsfraktion hat ihnen beiden einen
guten Morgen und Frau Schmidt es wird
viel geredet über Regelsätze über
Sanktionen über Schonvermögen das sind
alles wichtige Aspekte beim
bürgergeldgesetz aber sollen sie
eigentlich erreichen mit dem Vorhaben ja
ich glaube dass der Zentrale
Paradigmenwechsel ist der dass wir nicht
mehr drauf gucken die Menschen irgendwie
mit hohem Druck schnellstmöglichen
Arbeit zu bringen in irgendeiner Arbeit
sondern dass wir gucken dass sie
nachhaltig langfristig in Arbeit kommen
dass wir sie qualifizieren darin
unterstützen auch gute Arbeit zu machen
dass wir Sie begleiten und dass wir eben
nicht mehr diesen drehtüreffekt haben
wollen schnell in irgendeiner Arbeit und
dann schnell wieder im Jobcenter sondern
dass wir wollen dass ihren eigenen Weg
in Arbeit gehen und dann auch in Arbeit
bleiben und ich glaube dass dieser
individuelle Ansatz des Förderns dass es
glaube ich der Paradigmenwechsel den wir
den wir heute beschließen
Abschaffung des vermittlungsvorrangs
sind wir habe ich als Stichwort da auch
gefunden und hin zur Förderung auch
geringqualifizierter Herr gröber spricht
dagegen es spricht nichts dagegen und
ist übrigens Praxis in vielen Jobcentern
wenn ein Leistungsempfänger eine
Weiterbildung machen möchte dass
selbstverständlich Vorrang hat für
irgendeiner Tätigkeit für uns gilt
Vorrang für Vermittlung aber bei der
Eingliederung in Arbeit will die Ampel
ein Haushalt beschließen der 600
Millionen kürzt wir müssen noch gerade
heute wir haben 1,9 Millionen offene
Stellen 900.000 Langzeitarbeitslose
alles tun damit Menschen Teilhabe in
Arbeit erfahren Unterstützung erfahren
wir müssen besser werden beim fördern
aber wir dürfen nicht nachlassen beim
fordern und deswegen geht das Bürgergeld
in die völlig falsche Richtung sie
meinen fördern ist nicht mehr
hinreichend weil der Vorhaben der
Koalition es gibt einen Bericht der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit interne
Revision wird das genannt da wird
kritisch bei euch was machen eigentlich
die Jobcenter und wenn es da heißt in
50% der Maßnahmen seien diese nicht
zielführend dann ändert daran das
Bürgergeld nicht doch genau
lesen Sie bitte die Briefe ihrer
Personalräte Brand ich hoffe die sagen
wörtlich wir sind unter Tränen und wir
können unsere Arbeit nicht leisten und
ihre Kürzung seid untragbar der
kaltschloss sich diese Leser aber wenn
nicht den Haushalt jetzt haben sie ja
heute nicht zum Haushalten
bis wir den Haushalt beschließen dann
können wir das alles noch mal aufmachen
weiterrede habe ich auch schon lange
nicht mehr gehabt jetzt haben sie meinen
Interview umgekrempelt ich wollte sagen
das macht aber nichts weil ich wollte zu
dem Punkt ohnehin nur wenn sie sich
gegenseitig ins Wort fahren können wir
auch nicht weiter ich habe zwar gesagt
sie können aufeinander reagieren aber da
muss halt immer nur einer reden jetzt
kommen wir jetzt Frau Schmidt kommen wir
zu dem Punkt schon jetzt Frau Schmidt
kommen wir zu dem Punkt von Herrn Gröhe
und jetzt darf ich Sie bitten irgendwie
da direkt drauf Bezug zu nehmen erstens
ist natürlich genau das fördern das was
wir in den Blick nehmen durch diesen
Kooperationsvertrag durch diese
Kooperationsvereinbarung die mir Wachen
wollen ist ja genau das zu gucken
individuell was braucht eine Person was
braucht der Arbeitslose Mensch um wieder
in Arbeit zu kommen und wir haben das
die Möglichkeiten der Unterstützung
deutlich erweitert wir haben die
Möglichkeit geschaffen dreijährige
Ausbildung zu machen wir haben die
Möglichkeit geschaffen auch Grundbildung
noch mal ganz anders nachzuholen wir
haben das was wir gemeinsam gemacht
haben beim 16i nämlich ein begleitendes
Coaching
alle Arbeitsmarkt und wir haben für den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt gemeinsam ein
Coaching ein begleitendes Coaching als
Instrument geschaffen dass die Menschen
unterstützt werden darin auch diesen Weg
zu gehen und das hat sich als sehr gut
erwiesen das haben wir jetzt sozusagen
auch für die anderen Möglichkeiten wenn
man eine Ausbildung macht erweitert also
sozusagen das ganze Repertoire an
Unterstützung ist deutlich erweitert und
es wird eben genau dadurch dass wir den
vermittlungsvorrang abschaffen auch die
Möglichkeit gegeben groß zu tun was den
Haushalt anbelangt möchte ich Herrn
Gröhe bitten doch abzuwarten bis wir den
Haushalt beraten weil wir dann danach
noch mal drüber reden können ob das
gekürzt wird oder nicht derzeit den
Haushalt sie haben ein Haushalt
eingebracht der massiv kürzt bei der
Eingliederung in Arbeit und davon hat
sich niemand klar distanziert die
Jobcenter Personal hätte sagen
händeringend das ist unverantwortbar und
es nützt eben nicht ein Coaching ins
Gesetz zu schreiben und beim Coaching
und bei der Vermittlung 600 Millionen zu
kürzen und im übrigen reden Sie mit den
Praktikerinnen und Praktikern aus den
Jobcentern die sagen für die
hartnäckigen Verweigerer jeder
Kooperation braucht es dringend die
Möglichkeit Mitwirkung auch durch
Leistungskürzung durchzusetzen haben wir
das ja und das wollen sie nicht nein das
schaffen sie weitestens
falschen falschen Behauptungen nein also
seit Wochen hören jetzt bitte ich aber
mal festzustellen wer hier dauernd ins
Wort fällt es gibt eine Ampel Angst vor
Argumenten und deswegen wird gebrüllt
beleidigt und schon auf dem Schulhof
weiß man Jan tschuldigung das Wort Hetze
das Wort Lüge das haben Sie von uns
Sozialdemokraten nie gegenüber gehört
und das war hier im Plenum zu hören und
öffentlich von ihrem Parteivorsitzenden
und dann glauben Sie im Ernst durch
Arroganz der Mehrheit im Bundestag
gewinnen Sie eine Mehrheit im Bundesrat
sie verweigern uns die Anhörung des
Bundesrechnungshofs es ist ein
unterirdische Kultur und diese gefallen
mir dauernd ins Wort jetzt müssen keine
Argumente haben haben sie schlechtes
Benehmen jetzt müssen wir es mal
systematisieren also mit dem schlechten
Benehmen nachdem was sie an
Falschbehauptung in den letzten Monaten
in die Welt gesetzt haben das ist schon
atemberaubendreistigkeit zu haben
wo es bei ihnen falsch Behauptung gibt
ununterbrochen wurde der Eindruck
erweckt wir sein gegen höhere Regelsätze
sie können heute dafür stimmen sie
werden heute gegen höhere Regelsätze
stimmen und das müssen sie ab morgen
erklären den Widerspruch den Menschen
erklären warum sie gegen den Mindestlohn
gestimmt haben warum sie nicht auf eine
Erhöhung auf 12 Euro unterstützt haben
damit genau die Menschen die wenig
verdienen mehr haben damit
Geringverdiener unterstützt werden damit
genau dieser Abstand zwischen einem
Regelsatz und einem Einkommen größer
wird und dann da haben sie dagegen
gestimmt und jetzt sagen Sie aber dort
wo wir den Regelsatz erhöhen wo
sozusagen der Abstand dann wieder
geringer wird das müssen wir jetzt
sofort machen natürlich machen wir das
aber wir machen das im Gesamtpaket wir
machen das eben mit dem Stärken des
Forderns wir machen das eben mit der
Erhöhung des Regelsatzes wir machen das
alles gemeinsam so mit dem fortschreiben
der Dinge die auch wichtig sind für die
die gearbeitet haben und die sich schon
etwas aufgebaut haben die schon etwas
geschaffen haben damit dass wir das was
wir auch gemeinsam gemacht haben in der
großen Koalition nämlich dass wir eine
Karenzzeit für diejenigen haben die
schon etwas geleistet die sich etwas
geschaffen haben dass die nicht gleich
alles verlieren alles das ist sozusagen
ein Gesamtpaket und über das Gesamtpaket
reden wir dann auch gerne mit den
Ländern so und jetzt haben wir es glaube
ich jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen Ruhe
reingebracht da verstehen die Leute ja
auch viel mehr wir Herr Gröhe wenn sie
direkt noch mal erwidern wollen ich
würde dann gerne einzelne Punkte daran
gelassen dass wir für 12 Euro
Mindestlohn sind wir halten die
Entmachtung der Sozialpartner von
Gewerkschaften und Arbeitgebern für
falsch zweitens das ist ein Problem gibt
das räumt Herr Gabriel ein ehemaliger
spd-vorsitzer der da verwarnt ist lohne
sich nicht mehr zu arbeiten das erklärt
der Bundesrechnungshof und das erklärt
Christian Lindner wenn er sagt die
Erhöhung der Regelsätze machen zwingend
eine Erhöhung des Grundfreibetrages
erforderlich es geht uns darum übrigens
auch die Bundesagentur für Arbeit
schlägt ein schrittweises in Kraft
treten an jetzt sicherzustellen dass am
1 Januar höhere Regelsätze gezahlt
werden dass ein kluger Kompromiss neben
sich die Ampel verweigert wir haben ja
einen schrittweises in Kraft treten
indem wir zum Beispiel die Dinge wo der
Jobcenter sich darauf vorbereiten muss
die sind erst sozusagen für den Sommer
vorgesehen aber darauf muss man sich
eben vorbereiten und zum Vorbereiten das
wissen sie auch braucht man eine
gesetzliche Grundlage und genau deswegen
schaffen wir die zum ersten ersten
es wäre wünschenswert gewesen wenn die
Ampel in den letzten Wochen einen
Versuch unternommen hätte sachlich über
die grundsätzlichen Webfehler zu
diskutieren wir haben letztens wieder
fällt sie mir ins Wort als Beitrag zur
sachlichen Diskussion das nenne ich
schlechtes Benehmen also wir haben die
Länder der Union haben vor einer Woche
der Koalition ihre grundsätzlichen
Kritikpunkte übermittelt um die Chance
einzuräumen uns ein
Vermittlungsverfahren zu ersparen und es
vor dem Bundesrat zustimmungsfähig zu
machen das hat die Ampel nicht genutzt
das stimmt das hat ja Reaktionen gegeben
darauf es hat mir Vorschläge gegeben ich
habe das nicht zu bewerten die Länder
werden das bewerten die zentralen
Kritikpunkte von Sanktionen bis schon
Vermögen werden in dem Entgegenkommen
dem vermeint den überhaupt nicht
adressiert also das stimmt nicht und
deswegen wir sind in einem Zeitplan der
knapp ist das gebe ich ihnen zu 1 Januar
ist knapp aber es war der
kabinettszeitplan der Ampel es war der
parlam Zeitplan der Ampel und jetzt
versuchen Sie damit uns unter Druck zu
setzen weil ihnen die Argumente ausgehen
beleidigt der klingenball Frau Schmidt
also stimmt
ja es stimmt ja einfach es stimmt ja
einfach wieder nicht wir haben ja über
das Wochenende sind wir auf dem
Bundesrat zugegangen haben Kritikpunkte
aufgenommen und das übliche ist dass es
darauf dann sozusagen eine Reaktion gibt
und man dann sagt was Dankeschön dass
ihr auf uns zugekommen seid das und das
sind noch unsere Anliegen leider sind
die Gesprächsangebote die wir gemacht
haben nicht angenommen worden das kennen
wir aber schon und insofern hoffe ich
dass wir jetzt eine muntere Debatte
haben werden aber das danach alle wieder
zur Vernunft kommen und wir dann
wirklich diese sachliche Debatte mit den
Ländern führen können damit wir am 1.1
für die Menschen was Gutes hinkriegen wo
muss es sich denn an ihrer Meinung nach
Herr Gröhe bewegen dass der vielleicht
auch noch mal Bewegung reinkommt in der
derzeitraum ist ja in der Tat jetzt
relativ eng der Zeitplan ist der
Zeitplan der Ampel wir haben die
Kritikpunkte benannt als Unionsfraktion
die Arbeitsministerin und
Arbeitsminister der Union ich habe die
drei zentralen Punkte schon Vermögen
Karenzzeit und den weitestge Verzicht
auf die Möglichkeit von Leistungskürzung
ausdrücklich genannt und in diesem
Bereichen wird nichts geändert es sind
andere Punkte rehader greifen Sie
Vorschläge der Unionsfraktion auf das
ist in Ordnung aber in den zentralen
Kritikpunkten gehen Sie nicht auf die
Länder zu und das haben sie zu
verantworten und deswegen ich rate mal
jetzt langsam die Beleidigung
einzustellen wenn es zu einem
Vermittlungsverfahren kommt sollte man
nicht vorher schutzwegräumen müssen weil
man persönlich herabsetzend unions
Politiker als Trump als lügener als
Hetzer bezeichnet solche Töne haben sie
von niemandem gegenüber Hubertus Heil
oder Lars Klingbeil gehört es ist einzig
und allein die Ampel der die Argumente
ausgegangen sind muss man vielleicht für
den Hintergrund noch erklären die den
allen Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern die
da der direkte Bezug fehlt der
Hintergrund wartet waren Behauptung die
es gegeben hat oder Aussagen aus der
Union dass man mit
ALG2 mit Hartz IV besser leben kann als
wenn man tatsächlich arbeitet da gibt es
allerdings natürlich Studien die das
Gegenteil belegen und da gibt es glaube
ich auch einzelne die mittlerweile
einräumen dass es dann in der Tat nicht
ganz so schlimm es gibt unterschiedliche
Studien einige sind zurückgezogen es ist
sehr kompliziert zu berechnen weil es
mit Wohnungen muss man alles Beton Geld
bezieht übrigens der Arbeitnehmer der
solche Hilfen in Anspruch nimmt muss
dies im Einzelnen beantragen im
Einzelnen bedarfnachweisen all das was
man in anderen Fällen für unzumutbar
hält aber entscheidend ist doch von
Sigmar Gabriel bis zu Christian Lindner
sagen alle das Problem existiert
wirklich und das einfach in Bausch und
Bogen als Hetze abzutun ist unanständig
und Entschuldigung der Vergleich zur mit
Herrn Trump der eine Abwahl nicht
anerkennt dessen Fans das
parlamentstürme durch ein klingenball
ist das ein Angebot zum Kompromiss das
ist die Angst vor Argumenten durch
billige Sprüche aber jetzt haben sie
nicht dass die Union teilweise
genau jetzt werden wir als Hunde
bezeichnet Frau Schmidt das Benehmen der
Sozialdemokraten ist kein
kompromissstand jetzt das Gefühl ich
habe das Gefühl dass wir leider wieder
nicht in der Lage sind über die Sache zu
reden dass wir leider nicht ich habe ja
ja aber ich habe ich glaube sie haben
trotz dass ich ein paar Mal deutlich
machen musste dass sie etwas erzählen
was nicht stimmt genug Zeit gehabt ihre
Punkte zu machen insofern glaube ich
dass das schon
jeder Sekunde hier der Gong ertönen wird
und weil wir heute pünktlich im Plenum
sein wollen aus verschiedenen Gründen
vielen Dank Frau Schmid Hermann Gröhe
ist schon auf dem Weg vielen Dank auch
Ihnen das war ein Vorgeschmack meine
Damen und Herren auf das was Sie gleich
hier 68 Minuten lang im Plenum erwarten
können da wird es ja gewaltig hin und
her gehen sag ich mal vorsichtig wir
schauen in den Plenarsaal und ich wollte
Ihnen noch sagen dass diese heutige
Sitzung eröffnet werden wird von
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars mit einem
Gedenken an Werner Schulz der grünen
Politiker ist überraschend gestorben im
Schloss Bellevue während einer
Veranstaltung gestern er war von 1990
bis 2005 im Deutschen Bundestag und von
2009 bis 2014 im Europaparlament daran
wird Bärbel Bass jetzt erinnern und
deswegen gebe ich ganz schnell rein in
den Plenarsaal
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich wünsche einen guten
Morgen die Sitzung ist eröffnet
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gestern verstarb das frühere langjährige
Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestages und
des Europäischen Parlaments Werner
Schulz im Alter von 72 Jahren
wir trauern mit seiner Witwe Monika
Schulz und seinen Angehörigen
wir sind tief bestürzt über diesen
großen Verlust seinen Tod kam plötzlich
und viel zu früh
der DDR-Bürgerrechtler und spätere
grünpolitiker verstarb während einer
Veranstaltung im Schloss Bellevue mit
dem Titel wie erinnern wir den 9
November ein Tag zwischen Pogrom und
demokratischen Aufbrüchen
ausgerechnet am 9 November endete sein
Leben
Werner Schulz hatte sich dafür
eingesetzt dieses Datum das auch der Tag
des Mauerfalls ist zum Nationalfeiertag
unseres Wiener vereinigten Landes zu
machen
Werner Schulz stand für seine
Überzeugung ein
aufrichtig und mutig oft unbequem und
gegen den Strom mit scharfer Zunge und
klarem Blick und immer der
freiheitlichen Demokratie verpflichtet
für sein jahrzehntelang Einsatz für die
Demokratie und für die Opposition in
Russland wurde er im Juni mit dem
deutschen Nationalpreis geehrt
der frühere Bundespräsident Joachim
Gauck sagte in seiner Laudatio über
Werner Schulz ich zitiere
sein Leben hat ihn gelehrt dass unsere
Ängste nicht das letzte Wort haben
dürfen wenn wir tun was wir tun müssen
Zitat Ende
1968 als Panzer den Prager Frühling
niederwalsten war Werner Schulz gerade
18 Jahre alt um in der DDR studieren zu
dürfen musste er seine Sympathien für
den Prager Frühling verleugnen
schriftlich er unterzeichnete eine
Resolution die den Einmarsch der
Warschauer Pakt Truppen befürwortete
dieses Handeln gegen die eigene
Überzeugung prägte ihn er vergaß es nie
diesen Schmerz wollte er nicht noch
einmal erleben er wollte sein werden und
der Wahrheit verpflichtend handeln
dieser Anspruch führte ihn in die
Opposition seit den 1970er Jahren
engagierte er sich in der kirchlichen
Friedens Umwelt und Bürgerrechtsbewegung
sein Name war mit der friedlichen
Revolution und der Wiedervereinigung
unseres Landes verknüpft seit 1982
engagierte er sich im Pankower
Friedenskreis dem ersten unabhängigen
Friedenskreis unter dem Dach der Kirche
1989 kritisierte er offen die
gefälschten Kommunalwahlen und wurde
Mitbegründer des Neuen Forums dass er
sechsmal am zentralen rundentisch der
DDR vertrat während des
wiedervereinigungsprozesses setzte er
sich für eine neue Verfassung nach
Artikel 146 Grundgesetz ein
Werner Schulz war Mitglied der ersten
frei gewählten Volkskammer der DDR und
des ersten Bundestages der aus
gesamtdeutschen Wahlen hervorging
in diesem Bundestag war er Sprecher der
acht ostdeutschen Bündnis grünen
Abgeordneten er war Mitbegründer von
Bündnis 90 als Partei und ein Motor der
Vereinigung mit den westdeutschen Grünen
als Bundestagsabgeordneter und später
als Abgeordnete des Europäischen
Parlaments Europa immer wieder und
frühzeitig die Stimme für Freiheit und
Demokratie
manche seiner Positionen wie zu
Militärintervention in Bosnien oder zu
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine fanden
erst später Zustimmung
er vergaß nie die Unterstützung der
westdeutschen grün für die demokratische
Opposition in der DDR vor
als er 2006 in St Petersburg die
Journalistin Anna
politkorskaya kennenlernte und von ihr
über die Repression in Russland erfuhr
erinnerte er sich an diese Hilfe und
unterstützte seitdem die russische
Opposition
früher als andere früher als die meisten
von uns sah er Putins Gefährlichkeit und
Skrupellosigkeit sehr klar als Putin
2001 hier im Deutschen Bundestag sprach
verließ er vorzeitig das Plenum
schon vor Jahren kritisierte er dass die
westlichen Staatengemeinschaft Russlands
aggressiven Imperialismus entschieden
Einhalt hätte Gebieten müssen und die
Ukraine stärker schützen müsste im
Frühjahr sagte Werner Schulz in einem
Interview
zur Demokratie gehört Zivilcourage sich
nicht zu verbiegen und sich nicht
anzubiedern Zitat Ende
seine Haltung und seine Unabhängigkeit
machten ihn über Parteigrenzen hinweg zu
einem hochgeschätzten Politiker und
Menschen dieser mutige und aufrichtige
Kämpfer für die freiheitliche Demokratie
wird unserem Land fehlen
ich möchte sie nun bitten sich für eine
Schweigeminute als Zeichen unserer
Dankbarkeit und unserer Trauer um Werner
Schulz von den Plätzen zu erheben
[Musik]
ich danke Ihnen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor
Eintritt in die Tagesordnung begrüße ich
einen neuen Kollegen im Plenum Alexander
Barz hat heute für den ausgeschiedenen
Kollegen Falco Moors die Mitgliedschaft
in deutschen Bundestag erworben herzlich
willkommen und auf eine gute
Zusammenarbeit
ich komme nun zur Tagesordnung hier
werden Zusatzpunkt 6 Tagesordnungspunkt
Buchstabe b und Buchstabe C sowie
Tagesordnungspunkt 40 Buchstabe d
abgesetzt
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 10a
und 10b Beratung mehrerer Vorlagen zur
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes
wir werden später drei namentliche
Abstimmungen durchführen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache und das
Wort hat zu Beginn der Bundesminister
für Arbeit und Soziales Hubertus Heil
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich hatte gestern die
Gelegenheit ein Startup-Unternehmen
gestern Nachmittag in Berlin Wedding zu
besuchen das Unternehmen heißt Factory
ist ein Unternehmen das mittels einer
digitalen Plattform
Zulieferteile für
Maschinenbauunternehmen vermittelt das
Unternehmen hat 35 Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter und hat sich entschieden in
den letzten Jahren fünf
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen
einzustellen
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen die vom
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt profitieren mit
lohnkostenzuschüssen ich habe gestern
auch die Gelegenheit gehabt mit dreien
dieser Menschen zu sprechen dabei war
ein Mann der sage und schreibe 15 Jahre
lang arbeitslos war und das nicht weil
er zu faul war
sondern weil er ein Schicksalsschlag
hatte hätte Bankkaufmann gelernt hat
gearbeitet der ist dann erkrankt hat
seine Arbeit verloren es war eine
langjährige Erkrankung es ging
irgendwann gesundheitlich besser aber
jahrelang sich die fingerbund
geschrieben nach langen Jahren der
Arbeitslosigkeit ohne eine Chance auf
Arbeit wieder zu bekommen weil er zu
lange draußen war er hat meine Maßnahme
bekommen Bewerbungstraining aber hätte
nicht wirklich Arbeit finden können
meine Damen und Herren dieser Mann ist
heute in der Buchhaltung des
Unternehmens dessen wertvoller
Mitarbeiter in Zeiten in denen
händeringend Arbeits- und Fachkräfte
gesorgt werden und was wir mit dem
Bürgergeld machen ist dass wir den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt in Fristen damit
wir Menschen wie diesen eine Chance auf
selbstbestimmtes Leben in Arbeitgeber
das Bürgergeld meine Damen und Herren
ist die größte sozialstaatsreform seit
20 Jahren wir verfolgen als
Bundesregierung als Koalition damit vor
allen Dingen zwei Ziele ja es geht darum
dass Menschen die in existenzielle Not
geraten sind verlässlich und so
unbürokratisch wie möglich abgesichert
werden aber das reicht uns nicht wir
wollen nicht nur Schutz geben in Zeiten
der Not wir wollen Chancen auf den
selbstbestimmtes Leben schaffen ich habe
es eben am Beispiel dieses Mannes am
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt beschrieben aber
wir sagen das auch mit Blick auf die
Realität der Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit in
Deutschland wenn es so ist dass zwei
Drittel der Langzeitarbeitslosen
Menschen heute kein abgeschlossenen
Berufsabschluss haben und sie im alten
Hartz-IV-System dann hin und wieder
vielleicht mal in Hilfstätigkeiten
vermittelt werden aber das Jobcenter sie
nach ein paar Monaten wiedersieht und
sie nicht dauerhaft nachhaltig in Arbeit
vermittelt werden dann ist im System was
falsch mit dem Bürgergeld ändern wir das
wir schaffen die Chance dass Menschen
nicht in Hilfstätigkeiten werden müssen
sondern ein Berufsabschluss nachholen
können um dauerhaft und Arbeit zu sein
dass es auch ein Beitrag für Fachkräfte
und Arbeitskräfte
für den Bürgergeld reagieren wir auf
zwei fundamentale Veränderungen erstens
ist der Arbeitsmarkt heute ein völlig
anderer als vor 20 Jahren damals hatten
wir Massenarbeitslosigkeit heute in
vielen Bereichen Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel und zweitens ist es
wichtig aus den Erfahrungen der Krisen
der letzten Jahre auch der aktuellen
Krise zu lernen wenn es darum geht für
weniger Bürokratie im System und für
mehr Respekt für die Menschen zu sorgen
für Notlagen meine Damen und Herren
brauchen wir Lösungen die funktionieren
so unbürokratisch und so
bürgerfreundlich wie möglich wir sorgen
mit den Bürgergeld dafür dass wir
überflüssige Bürokratie in den
Jobcentern abbauen damit die
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeiter in der
Jobcenter die übrigens eine
hervorragende Arbeit leisten tatsächlich
sich auf das Wesentliche konzentrieren
können ein Beispiel ist das was die
Jobcenter immer gefordert haben zum
Beispiel eine Bagatellgrenze für
Kleinstbeträge wo Menschen mit
Bescheiden belästigten überzogen werden
dann lohnt wieder Aufwand noch nutzen
das schaffen wir
vor allen Dingen meine Damen und Herren
aber sorgen wir für angemessenen Schutz
ein wichtiger Teil der Reform ist die
Erhöhung des Regelsatzes es geht darum
dass das Bürgergeld was die Erhöhung und
Anpassung der Regelsätze betrifft der
Inflationsentwicklung zukünftig nicht
mehr hinterherlaufen das ist gerade
jetzt besonders wichtig aber ich sage
auch klar und deutlich damit kann es
nicht getan sein die Qualität eines
Sozialstaats bemisst sich nicht allein
an der Höhe des sozialen Transfers
sondern die Qualität ist Sozialstaats
bemisst sich vor allen Dingen daran wie
sehr er in der Lage ist Menschen zu
einem selbstbestimmten Leben am Arbeit
zu bringen und ich sage es noch mal ein
Beispiel des Mannes den ich eingangs
genannt habe der hat mir erzählt was er
in den 15 Jahren erlebt hat wie er sich
die fingerbund geschrieben hat wie ihm
die Decke auf den Kopf gefallen ist und
dem Mann geht es heute besser in Arbeit
er sagt ich fühle mich wertgeschätzt ich
leiste was ich habe Kolleginnen Kollegen
meine Damen und Herren für die Mehrheit
der Menschen in Deutschland ist Arbeit
mehr als Broterwerb es ist Geld
verdienen aber es ist Teilhabe am
gesellschaftlichen Leben und damit
sorgen wir auch mit Bürgergeld dafür
dass Leistungssystem
und wir setzen Anreize ein
Berufsabschluss nachzuholen ermöglichen
das nicht nur wenn wir das einmal bei
Menschen erlebt hat die ein
Berufsabschluss verpasst haben die sich
dann wieder aufrappeln das ist sehr
anstrengend und wir wollen das
leistungszielt und das auch mit
finanziellen Anreizen belohnt wird mit
dem Weiterbildungsgeld wir werden dafür
sorgen und da bin ich den
koalitionsfraktion sehr dankbar dass wir
uns darauf verständigt haben dass wir
Zuverdienstgrenzen im Bürgergeld erhöhen
damit Leistung sich lohnt das war nicht
nur ein Anliegen der FDP aber die FDP
hat sich besonders dafür eingesetzt ganz
herzlichen Dank dafür
und jetzt meine Damen und Herren muss
ich an die Adresse der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion mal meiner
Verwunderung Ausdruck bringen dass sie
heute den Antrag stellen dass nur der
Regelsatz erhöht wird wenn sie
wochenlang rumlaufen und sagen mit den
Bürgergeld lohnt sich Arbeit nicht mehr
und gleichzeitig nur den Regelsatz
erhöhen dann ist ein gewisser logischer
Bruch muss ganz deutlich zu sagen
denn Arbeit muss ein Unterschied machen
arbeit muss sich lohnen in Deutschland
und dafür sorgt die Koalition deshalb
haben wir den Mindestlohn erhöht meine
Damen und Herren auf 12 Euro und die
cdu/csu hat nicht mitbestimmt
deshalb kämpfen wir für mehr
Tarifbindung und brauchen auch da noch
ein bisschen Unterstützung kann die
Union sich auch verdient machen deshalb
haben wir das Wohngeld heute auf der
Tagesordnung gerade in diesen Zeiten
deshalb haben wir Beiträge und Steuern
für Geringverdiener gesorgt den Arbeit
müssen Unterschied machen aber in diesen
Zeiten in denen die gesellschaftliche
Stimmung angespannt ist aufgrund der
Krise werden und dürfen keine
demokratischen Demokraten zulassen das
geringverdienende Menschen gegen
bedürftige Menschen ausgespielt werden
wir müssen die gesamte Gesellschaft im
Blick haben und dieses Land
zusammenhalten
nämlich mit zwei Kritikpunkten noch
auseinandersetzen die heute auch
vorgetragen werden zum einen die
sogenannte Karenzzeit in der wir uns
erstmal wir Menschen bedürftig geworden
sind nicht angucken die Angemessenheit
des Wohnraums weil wir eben Menschen
nicht verunsichern wollen die Not
geraden sind dass sie auch noch ihre
Wohnung verlieren sondern sich darauf
konzentrieren können wie dein Arbeit zu
kommen und richtig wir greifen kleines
Erspartes auch nicht an das haben wir
übrigens mit der CDU mal eingeführt vor
zwei Jahren weil wir da in der Krise
erlebt haben wie das ist wenn
soloselbstständige beispielsweise auf
einmal in Not geraten und dann ihr
ganzes Erspartes aufbauen müssen das ist
auch eine Frage des Respekts vor
Lebensleistung leistung muss sich lohnen
in Deutschland
dann wird noch behauptes gäbe keine
Sanktionen mehr richtig ist dass wir die
Sanktionen Mitwirkungspflichten auf die
Bereiche konzentrieren auf die
hartnäckigen Fälle in das notwendig ist
aber der Geist des Bürgergeldes meine
Damen und Herren ist nicht der dass wir
alle Menschen die langzeitarbeit zu sind
unter Verdacht Stellen zu faul zu sein
zu Arbeit die meisten wollen arbeiten
der geistesbürgergelds ist der der
Solidarität des Zutrauens der Ermutigung
und deshalb haben wir gute Gründe dass
heute zu beschließen am Montag ist der
Bundesrat dran vielleicht gibt es eine
Mehrheit dafür wir haben gute Argumente
zu überzeugen unsere Hand ist
ausgestreckt wir haben viele Anträge des
Bundesrates übernommen auch von
unionsgeführten Ländern ich hoffe darauf
Vernunft statt auf Parteitaktik denn da
sitzen Ministerpräsident
Ministerpräsidenten und eben nicht
Mitarbeiter
aber falls es am Montag noch keine mehr
den Bundesrat gibt wird die
Bundesregierung den
Vermittlungsausschuss anrufen dann haben
wir die Gelegenheit in einem schnellen
Verfahren dafür zu sorgen dass das
Bürgergeld am 1 Januar in Kraft tritt es
wird dann gestuft umgesetzt damit die
Jobcenter nicht überlastet werden aber
wichtig ist meine Damen und Herren dass
wir die im Blick haben um die es geht
die Menschen die jetzt auf das
Bürgergeld angewiesen sind herzlichen
Dank
Hubertus Heil der Bundesarbeitsminister
mit seinen Erläuterungen zum
bürgergeldgesetz und jetzt folgt ihm
Hermann Gröhe stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion der wie
wir wissen aus dem Interview vor wenigen
Minuten da eine deutlich andere Position
hat
Kolleginnen und liebe Kollegen ja Herr
Minister es geht um Menschen wie den von
Ihnen genannten Langzeitarbeitslosen die
wir besser in Arbeit vermitteln besser
unterstützen wollen und deswegen ist es
richtig dass sie den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt den wir gemeinsam
geschaffen haben in Fristen aber es ist
völlig verfehlt dass sie in der Bereich
der Integration in Arbeit 600 Millionen
Euro kürzen wollen tun sie doch nicht so
als hilft ein neu Name wenn sie beim
Geld für die Jobcenter kürzen für uns
als Union war stets klar Vorfahrt für
Vermittlung wir halten am fordern fest
aber wir müssen beim fördern besser
werden wir wollen nicht das alles so
bleibt wie sie es permanent unterstellen
bis heute verweigern sie jede sachliche
Debatte über die grundsätzlichen
Webfehler ihres Gesetzes ich dachte
zunächst da sei die ampelangst vor
Argumenten inzwischen weiß ich sie haben
sogar vor unseren fragenangst es ist
doch ungeheuerlich dass sie es der
Opposition verweigern den
Bundesrechnungshof in einer Anhörung
dieses Parlaments zu befragen eine
Institution der das Grundgesetz
richterliche Unabhängigkeit zuschreibt
und sie wollen diese Antworten nicht im
Parlament hören unglaublich
glauben Sie eigentlich im Ernst glauben
Sie im Ernst die Arroganz der Mehrheit
im Bundestag erhöht die Chancen auf eine
Mehrheit im Bundesrat wer empfiehlt ihn
eigentlich so absurde Strategien bis
doch unglaublich ja die Zeit wird knapp
wir wollen am 1 Januar bessere
Bedingungen für die Menschen die
langzeitarbeitslos sind aber der
kabinettszeitplan ist der
kabinettszeitplan der Ampel der
parlamentszeitplan ist der
parlamentszeitplan der Ampel wir haben
zu keiner Zeit irgendetwas verzögert im
Gegenteil es waren die
arbeitsministerinnen und Minister der
Union die vor einer Woche an Sie als
Fraktionen der Ampel geschrieben haben
um welche grundsätzlichen Bedenken es
ging wir wollten uns ein
Vermittlungsverfahren ersparen wir
wollten Ihnen die Gelegenheit geben sich
zu korrigieren Sie haben die ungenutzt
verstreichen lassen
und trotz aller persönlichen
Herabsetzungen sei mal darauf
hingewiesen die Personalräte der
Jobcenter drängen auf eine Verschiebung
sie schreiben lesen Sie den Brandbrief
sie drängen darauf
sie nein ich weiß dass sie das Herr dürr
also im Schulhof gilt wer brüllt hat
Unrecht für Herrn Bürgel das sogar im
Parlament meine Damen meine Herren also
das originell
also jetzt lassen sie nicht mal etwas zu
den Personalräten sagen dass die FDP
sich nicht dafür interessiert ist ja in
Ordnung aber so kalt schnäuzig wie die
SPD mit diesem Personalräten umgeht
sollten Sie aufhören andere über
Mitbestimmung zu belehren das ist die
Wahrheit
da schreiben ihnen Personalräte dass die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen den Tränen nahe
sind und schlagen vor vorzuziehen die
Regelsatzerhöhung das ist der Vorschlag
von Friedrich Merz sie wischen dies vom
Tisch meine Damen meine Herren wir sind
für die möglichst zeitnah Erhöhung darum
geht es es geht niemand darum
irgendjemand aus gegeneinander
auszuspielen es geht darum ein Jahr zu
haben zu den höheren Regelsätzen und in
den Blick zu nehmen die Lage der
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen und Herr
klingball ich zitiere ihren Vorgänger
Sigmar Gabriel er sagt er sei kein
besonderer Fan des Bürgergelds dann
geht's weiter es führe dazu Zitat Klinge
Zitat Gabriel Zitat dass diejenigen die
als wenig qualifiziertem Handwerk
arbeiten im Zweifel keinen ökonomischen
Anreiz mehr haben arbeiten zu gehen ihr
Vorgänger nach wo müssen sie jetzt
Genosse Trump sagen das ist nur Art
peinlich und Christian Lindner erklärt
wenn der Regelsatz steigt dann müsse der
Grundfreibetrag erhöht werden damit
räumt er genau ein dass wir recht haben
ich befürchte nur der FDP-Vorsitzende
Lindner wird ihm vorwerfen das sei
schäbigkeitswettbewerb so ist das wenn
man ein bisschen schizophren
argumentiert sie lehnen es ab sie wollen
es heute ablehnen den Regelsatz zu
erhöhen aber dann haben sie am Montag
kein Recht die Länder damit unter Druck
zu setzen man müsse ihrem Gesetz
uneingeschränkt zustimmen sonst enthalte
man Arbeitslosen die fällige Erhöhung
vor heute gab heute gibt es einen
Namensliste wer war dafür und wer war
dagegen das ist sehr eindeutig
und da sie am liebsten Streit schreien
sage ich Ihnen mit Denkverboten kommen
sie nicht weiter und ich sage sehr
deutlich wir wollen nicht lediglich eine
Erhöhung der Regelsätze wir wollen auch
wir haben Vorschläge gemacht wir lehnen
auch nicht alles bei Ihnen ab um das
klar zu sagen
Hinzuverdienstgrenzen erhöhen haben wir
uns als Unionsfraktion zu bekannt nein
das stimmt einfach nicht aber sie packen
die zentralen Webfehler nicht ein es
geht eben im Kern um ein Schonvermögen
bei einer Bedarfsgemeinschaft mit zwei
Kindern von 150.000 Euro die man
besitzen kann und trotzdem Bürgergeld
bekommen kann die Mehrheit der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer kann
von einem solchen vermögen nur träumen
und wissen Sie sie gefährden damit die
Fairness die gefährden damit die
Fairness in diesem Land aber was viel
schlimmer ist sie gefährden damit die
Chancen auf Vermittlung in Arbeit
erlauben Sie mir einen Landrat zu
zitieren es ist unerklärlich dass in
einer Zeit in der die Gesellschaft zur
Bewältigung von Krisen und ihren
Aufgaben zwingend das
Arbeitskräftepotenzial erhöhen muss
die Wege aus der Arbeitslosigkeit
eingeschränkt und die Wege in die
Arbeitslosigkeit erleichtert werden
dieser Landrat Peter Pohlmann ist
Mitglied der SPD in Niedersachsen Herr
Klingbeil wahrscheinlich auch so
eingenossen Tram es ist doch
ungeheuerlich sie preisen sich die
Preisen sich für die angeblich größte
sozialstaatsreform aber sie wissen Weg
die Kritik des deutschen Städte und
Gemeindebundes sie wissen Weg die Kritik
des Deutschen Städtetages sie wissen Weg
die Kritik des Landkreistages wie viel
ideologische verbotheit braucht man
eigentlich um so mit der Kritik
derjenigen umzugehen die unseren
Sozialstaat vor Ort tragen mit dieser
Arroganz bringen Sie den Sozialstaat
nicht nach vorne mit dieser Arroganz
werden sie scheitern
Hermann Gröhe war das stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion hat
einige Punkte hier natürlich auch noch
mal betont die wir schon im Interview
mit ihnen gehört haben heute um viertel
vor neun wo es auch richtig sags mal
vorsichtig lebendig zugehen Britta
Hasselmann ist die nächste Rednerin in
dieser Aussprache der ja nicht nur der
Gesetzentwurf der Koalition zugrunde
liegt sondern auch drei Anträge aus der
Linksfraktion und einer aus der
afd-fraktion zum Thema bürgergeldgesetz
und jetzt wie gesagt Britta Hasselmann
die Vorsitzende der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
die Diskussion über eine dieser größten
Sozialreformen der letzten Jahrzehnte
nämlich das Bürgergeld ist eine sehr
wichtige und sie wird sehr kontrovers
geführt
lieber Hermann Gröhe ich habe sie hier
schon sehr oft reden gehört und ich
schätze sie sehr aber ihre Rede hat
gezeigt wie schwer es ihnen fällt die
Position von Friedrich Merz und Söder zu
vertreten
meine Damen und Herren wer keine
Argumente in der Sache hat verliert sich
im Verfahren und das wird dem Anliegen
das mit dem Bürgergeld verbunden wird
mit den vielen Menschen die davon
profitieren werden und die betroffen
sind in keiner Weise gerecht meine Damen
und Herren und
einst fest Friedrich Merz spitzt zwar
die Lippen öffentlich ja und er geht
sich in Vorurteilen gegenüber Menschen
die betroffen sind die von
Arbeitslosigkeit betroffen sind die arm
sind die in prekären
Beschäftigungsverhältnissen Leben schürt
sozial Neid ohne Ende eine solche
soziale Kälte in Krisenzeiten kaum zu
ertragen und verantwortungslos aber hier
im Parlament
wir im Parlament kneift er heute es ist
auch einfacher Interviews zu geben bei
denen keiner widersprechen kann meine
Damen und Herren weil heute wären wir
mit ihren Argumenten die sie öffentlich
führen mit Ihnen hier scharf ins Gericht
gegangen meine Damen und Herren
aber meine Damen und Herren es geht halt
um die
Lebenswirklichkeiten die sind in diesem
Land verschieden
und wie soll jemand der in einer ganz
anderen Lebenswirklichkeit lebt und sich
vielleicht überlegen muss ob er zur
Party mit dem Privatjet oder mit dem
Auto oder den Zug fliegt wie soll
so
sich in die Lebenswirklichkeit einer
allein sie Erziehenden Frau versetzen
die überlegen muss ob sie ein paar neue
Turnschuhe
[Applaus]
für das Vulkan oder ob sie vielleicht
heute einen Ausflug machen kann in einer
Eisdiele und mehr als drei Kugeln Eis
für ihre drei Kinder drin sind da kann
man auch nicht
erwarten dass man sich da reinversetzen
kann aber was ich von ihnen erwarte ist
Respekt Respekt vor der Lebenslage eines
jeden Menschen und den haben sie nicht
meine Damen und Herren
das Bürgergeld ist viel mehr als eine
Regelsatzerhöhung und deshalb
beschließen wir es heute auch insgesamt
es ist eine Reform des Arbeitsmarktes es
wird Veränderungen bringen denn meine
Damen und Herren
das Büro und Weiterbildung es schafft
Perspektiven für Menschen und
selbstverständlich geht es um
Vermittlung aber es geht nicht mehr
einfach nur um bloße Vermittlung sondern
um Qualifizierung und Beschäftigung
meine Damen und Herren es geht um
Fortbildungen es geht um
kooperationsperspektiven und wenn man
keine Ahnung hat vom Thema dann kann man
das vielleicht nicht sehen aber es ist
der Ansatz die Brücke für Menschen in
den Arbeitsmarkt zu verbessern indem man
ihn Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung
gibt und nicht einfach nur auf prekäre
Arbeits- oder
hilfsarbeitsangebote setzt und das ist
mit der bürgergeld-reform verbunden und
da kann niemand dagegen sein und wenn
man die Rede von Karl-Josef Laumann im
Bundesrat gehört hat hat er uns doch
gerade da unterstützt Hubertus Heil bei
der Frage wir brauchen mehr
Qualifizierung Weiterbildung wir
brauchen Fortbildung und und und und
alles wichtige Maßnahmen von denen ist
nichts mehr zu hören auf dieser Seite
denn Sachargumente spielen keine Rolle
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
enorme Chance zur Entbürokratisierung es
ist eine enorme Chance auch für
Wirtschaft Handwerk und Industrie denn
die warten alle auf facharbeitskräfte
wir haben eine fachkräftekrise in dieser
Gesellschaft und es ist wichtig deshalb
diese beiden Fragen zu verknüpfen all
das ist mit dem Bürgergeld verbunden und
sie wissen es im Kern auch meine Damen
und Herren und die Anpassung der
Regelsätze in dieser Krisenzeit ist
natürlich mehr als notwendig denn viele
der Menschen die auf Grundsicherung
angewiesen sind wissen doch am 20 des
Monats nicht mehr wie sie bis zum 31
kommen angesichts der Verteuerung der
Lebenssituation und deshalb meine Damen
und Herren es ist insgesamt ein gutes
Paket eine soziale Reform die eben auch
Vermittlung auf die Frage von
Qualifizierung und Beschäftigung auf
Ermutigung und Hilfe setzt und deshalb
lassen Sie uns darüber weiter
diskutieren wir hoffen auf die
Zustimmung und Unterstützung vieler
danke
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Norbert Kleinwächter
[Applaus]
werte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stehen an
der Seite derer die hart arbeiten die
einen Schicksalsschlag erleiden und dann
auf unsere Hilfe angewiesen sind
deswegen befürworten wir die Erhöhung
des Regelsatzes im SGB 2 meine Damen und
Herren denn es sind nicht unsere
Arbeitslosen die für diese völlig irren
Preissteigerungen verantwortlich sind
die Verantwortung dafür tragen unsere
Bundesregierung die EU-Kommission und
die Europäische Zentralbank mit ihrer
völlig Viren Niedrigzins und
transformationspolitik und vor dieser
Politik müssen wir die Menschen und
unsere Arbeitslosen auch schützen
[Applaus]
aber das Bürgergeld geht ja noch viel
weiter das Bürgergeld hilft nicht denen
die arbeiten wollen hilft nicht denen
die Leistung zeigen wollen das
Bürgergeld unterstützt diejenigen die
nicht arbeiten wollen und deswegen ist
es unsozial sie bringen Leistungen aus
an Leute die nicht arbeiten wollen auf
Kosten und Lasten derer die jeden Morgen
zur Arbeit gehen einstempeln ausstempeln
die Verantwortung tragen in ihren
Berufen die auch ein Risiko eingehen in
ihren Berufen ihr Risiko einen Job zu
verlieren ihr Risiko vielleicht ihren
Wohlstand zu verlieren wenn Sie
selbstständig sind ihr Risiko ihre
Gesundheit zu verlieren ein Risiko geht
ein bürgergeldempfänger nicht ein meine
Damen und Herren
und schauen wir uns doch mal die
Verbesserungen an sie nennen das ja so
die sie da vorschlagen
wem nützt es denn dass man ein
Einfamilienhaus in Münchener nobel vor
Ort behalten kann mit 140 Quadratmeter
Wohnfläche und einem Wert von über einer
Million Euro ist dieser Mensch bedürftig
nein er ist es nicht wem nützt es denn
dass man in unbegrenzter Höhe wohnen und
Heizkosten jetzt nennen sie es ja
Übernahme angemessene Heizkosten bei
einer unangemessenen Wohnfläche dass man
das alles machen darf das nützt doch
nicht demjenigen der schon immer
angemessen und vernünftig gewohnt hat
meine Damen und Herren und wem nützt es
das sechs Monate lang man sich vor
seinen Jobcenter Mitarbeiterin setzen
kann sie breit angrenzen kann sagen kann
ich habe keine Lust und es passiert
genau gar nichts das hilft nicht
denjenigen die arbeiten wollen das hilft
nur denjenigen die nicht arbeiten wollen
und deswegen ist ihr Bürgergeld keine
Reform des Sozialstaats sondern eine
Beleidigung des Sozialstaats
und wie simpel grün rot denkt das hat
der Frau Hasselmann gerade dargestellt
aber dass ich ausgerechnet der FDP mal
die Grundsätze des gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalts erklären müssen das hätte
ich mir nicht gedacht aber ich tu es
trotzdem unsere Gesellschaft basiert auf
einem ständigen Geben und Nehmen in
Wirtschaft in Handel in der Arbeit ja
man gibt Leistung man bekommt ein Gehalt
in der Schule man gibt Aufmerksamkeit
man bekommt Bildung nur im Bürgergeld da
gibt man gar nichts und man bekommt
trotzdem meine Damen und Herren und man
bekommt sogar so viel dass ein
Niedriglohnempfänger fast schlechter
dasteht als ein bürgergeldempfänger und
da wir uns doch nicht wundern Frau NASA
da müssen wir uns doch nicht wundern
dass Leute statt selber auf dem Bau zu
gehen lieber bei RTL2 anderen beim Bauen
zugucken nur davon hilft davon
profitiert unsere Wirtschaft nicht wir
haben fast eine Million offene Stellen
in niedrig und unqualifizierten Bereich
und sie reden von Qualifizierung
übrigens auch für diejenigen die sich
nie haben qualifizieren wollen und
wissen Sie was das schlimme ist bitte im
Bürgergeld helfen sie niemandem der
wirklich Hilfe braucht
sie verhöhnen diejenigen die jeden Tag
zur Arbeit gehen und sie stigmatisieren
diejenigen die wirklich nicht arbeiten
können denn in der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung werden die doch in einen
Topf geworfen mit all den Chaos potatos
die eben nicht nicht können sondern die
nicht wollen ein Sozialsystem muss
diejenigen schützen die Arbeiten
denjenigen helfen die es nicht können
und diejenigen motivieren die es nicht
wollen
Norbert Kleinwächter ist
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
afd-fraktion und der Bundestag
diskutiert über das bürgergeldgesetz der
Koalition nächster Redner Johannes Vogel
ist erster parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der FDP-Fraktion und hat
mal eine Bundesagentur Filiale in
Wuppertal Solingen geleitet liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Demokratie lebt
vom Wettstreit der Argumente und die
Opposition soll deswegen natürlich die
Koalition kritisieren auch beim
Bürgergeld nehmen wir das Beispiel schon
vermögen wir sind der Meinung dass wenn
zum Beispiel ein selbstständiger durch
einen Schicksalsschlag auf die
Grundsicherung angewiesen ist dass er
nicht als erstes seine Altersvorsorge
aufbrauchen soll sie sehen das anders
das ist ihr gutes Recht darüber können
wir hier streiten
es macht aber einen zentralen
Unterschied und das hat ist bei mir bei
dieser Debatte wirklich wichtig es macht
einen zentralen Unterschied ob man ein
alternatives politisches Urteil fällt
oder ob man alternative Fakten erfindet
und das haben wir hier in der
bürgerkette erlebt wir brauchen in der
Demokratie und das ist mir wirklich
ernst eine gemeinsame debattengrundlage
auf Basis von Fakten und
mir liegt hier der sitzungswöchentliche
Brief von Friedrich Merz aus der letzten
Sitzungswoche erste Lesung Bürgergeld
vor wo sich schwarz auf weiß Aussagen
finden die wir auch die letzten Tage
immer wieder in der Debatte gehört haben
mit dem Bürgergeld soll eine
sechs-monatige sanktionsfreie Karenzzeit
eingeführt werden sagen Sie Herr Merz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt nicht es
gibt keine sanktionsfreien Zeiten im
Bürgergeld sondern 80 Prozent der
Sanktionen werden auch den ersten sechs
Monaten weiter verhängt und danach sogar
das volle verfassungsrechtlich mögliche
Maße es ist kein Geheimnis Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Grünen nennen sich das
anders gewünscht das ist auch okay in
einer Demokratie aber wer etwas anderes
verbreitet der verbreitet Fake News und
das geht nicht in der demokratischen
Debatte
ein weiteres Zitat aus ihrem Brief die
Regelsätze sollen über die
Inflationsanpassung hinaus angehoben
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union an der rechnungsmethode der
Regelsätze ändert sich nichts zu Recht
gleichen wir die Inflation nicht mehr
anderthalb Jahre später aus das auch
eine Frage der Fairness und ja es ist
bekannt manche Kollegen Kollegen aus
Koalitionsfraktionen von SPD und Grünen
hätten sich eine andere
Berechnungsmethode gewünscht aber das
steht nicht im Gesetzentwurf den wir
hier beraten und vollends schizophren
wird es wenn sie behaupten durch das
Bürgergeld lohne sich Arbeit in
Deutschland nicht mehr das ist erstens
in jedem einzelnen Fall falsch und
zweitens polymisieren sie damit gegen
eine Berechnungsmethode der Regelsätze
die eine CDU-Ministerin selber
eingeführt hat liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist doch schizophren und
unredlich
vollends
vollends verrückt wird es dann mit ihrem
move dieser Woche dass sie die
ich nehme gerne eine Zwischenfrage
wollte ich gerade das wollte ich dir
gerade fragen also sie dürfen Herr
Kleinwächter
wertekollege Vogel sie haben gerade
kritisiert dass von der oppositionsseite
vorgetragen wird Arbeiten lohne sich
nicht mehr im bürgergeldbezug und dass
sie sagen es lohnt sich immer
sind wir uns einig dass sich lohnen
prinzipiell schon mal eine subjektive
Kategorie ist und sind wir uns zu dem
einig dass wenn jemand ein Mindestlohn
verdient Vollzeit arbeitet da landet bei
1404 Euro netto Steuerklasse 1
dass der gerade wenn er in einer sehr
großen Wohnung wohnt mit sehr
umfangreichen Wohn- und Heizkosten plus
Regelbedarf im Endeffekt im
bürgergeldbezug fast auf das gleiche
kommt wie wenn er entsprechend dieses
Gehalt verdient ja er hat den
Zuverdienst ja er hat den Selbstbehalt
ja er hat die 20 30 Prozent je nach
Stufe in Gera ist in der im Endeffekt
noch zu verdienen kann aber bei den
200-300 Euro die es rauskommt würden sie
wirklich behaupten dass es sich lohnt
jeden Morgen aufzustehen 40 Stunden die
Wochen in die Arbeit zu gehen eben nicht
mehr die Supermarkt Prospekte durchgehen
zu können für das günstigste essen
sondern auswärts essen gehen müssen ein
autoverhalten zu müssen und all das und
würden Sie nicht auch annehmen dass
durch Abzug all diese
Opportunitätskosten faktisch für diese
Menschen bei Ihrem System ein Verlust
entsteht
die
frage ich gebe mir die Gelegenheit etwas
aufzuklären was in den letzten Tagen
auch in der Debatte irreführend war
richtig ist dass in unserem Sozialstaat
übrigens vorgegeben durch Rechtsprechung
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts die
Ansprüche auf das Existenzminimum zum
Beispiel bei großen Familien so hoch
sind dass ein allein verlieren mit
Mindestlohn das nicht alleine durch sein
Arbeitslohn erwirtschaftet das ist
richtig das ist Ausdruck auch des
sozialstaatsprinzips das gibt unsere
Verfassung vor das hat aber genau nichts
mit dem Bürgergeld zu tun weil das heute
schon so der Fall ist und auch
richtigerweise der Fall ist die Frage
ist also wie können wir dafür sorgen
dass sich Anstrengung zum Beispiel auch
bei diesen großen Familien wenn Menschen
arbeiten stärker lobt heute schon gibt
es keinen Fall wo der der arbeitet
weniger hat als der der nicht arbeitet
und das ist auch richtig durch
Kindergeld Kinder Rückschlag Wohngeld
all das was wir auch jetzt Anpassen an
die Inflation aber richtig ist es muss
sich stärker lohnen und dann muss man an
ein Thema ran was mir in der Tat sehr am
Herzen liegt nämlich das Thema
zuverdienstregeln und deshalb ist es
auch so absurd was die Union diese Woche
vorschlägt nämlich einfach nur die
Regelsätze zu erhöhen ohne durch die
Reform des Bürgergeldes auch für mehr
Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen zu sorgen das müssen
wir doch
tun Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt es
gibt eine weitere Zwischenfrage von
Herrn birkwald aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE ich würde jetzt gerne den Gedanken
kurz zu Ende führen der Kollege Matthias
birkwald verzeiht mir das gut
nein das ist die Wahrheit ich erinnere
mich gut an meine erste politische
Verhandlung als junger Abgeordneter in
der schwarz-gelben Koalition mit dem
cdu-kanzleramtsminister der CDU
Arbeitsministerin und ich habe mich
dafür eingesetzt dass die zuverdienste
reformiert werden sie ich habe mich
damals nicht durchsetzen können weil sie
Angst vor statistik-effekten hatten ich
habe das aber nicht vergessen weil wir
an diese Ungerechtigkeit unseres
Sozialstaats endlich ran müssen es muss
sich mehr lohnen Schritt für Schritt
rauszuwachsen aus der Grundsicherung und
das schaffen wir jetzt endlich das ist
Kern der Bürger der Reform liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und damit machen wir übrigens auch klar
dass junge Menschen diesem Land endlich
stärker Piloten des eigenen Lebens
werden heute lohnt sich nämlich auch
eine Ausbildung nicht das machen wir
anders das machen wir besser durchs
Bürgergeld heute werden zum Beispiel
wenn Annika die in einer
hartz-iv-familie groß wird im Minijob
arbeitet kann sie von 520 Euro 184
behalten wenn eische deren Eltern
finanziell auf eigenen Beinen stehen
denselben Minijob macht dann kann sie
520 Euro behalten junge Menschen
Verfahren schon in diesem Land heute vor
dem Bürgergeld am Anfang ihres Lebens
dass ich ihre Anstrengung nicht lohnt
das ist kein Unterschied macht wenn sie
arbeiten dass sie schlechtere Chancen
haben wegen weil ihre Eltern in
schwieriger Lagen sind das ist das
Gegenteil von Chancen Unabhängigkeit
unabhängig von der Herkunft und das
verbessern wir endlich
durch mehr Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen
das macht nämlich vor allem was in den
Köpfen meine Fraktion hat diese Woche
drei junge Menschen nach Berlin
eingeladen Ferrat Sarah und Alex jeder
kann sich ihre Geschichten gerade seit
heute morgen auf Youtube anschauen sie
beschreiben sehr eindrücklich was das
was das in den Köpfen und den Herzen
macht wenn man schlechtere Chancen hat
wegen der Familie in die man geboren
wurde wir müssen uns doch nicht wundern
dass in unserem Land Chancen stärker von
der Herkunft abhängen wenn wir bereits
am Anfang des Lebens junge Menschen
Steine in den Weg legen das schaffen wir
endlich ab und darauf bin ich stolz denn
für diese Menschen kämpfen wir und
machen unser Sozialstaat fairer deshalb
stimmen wir heute für das Bürgergeld
vielen Dank
Johannes Vogel der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
FDP-Fraktion in der Debatte zum
bürgergeldgesetz
und da warten wir jetzt auf Dietmar
Bartsch den Vorsitzenden der
Linksfraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
aktuell erleben das ist nicht anders zu
bezeichnen als ein Schmierentheater die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben angesichts der
Krise höhere Steuern für die
Topverdiener verlangt völlig zu Recht
und sie die Union lehnen das ab sie
spielen stattdessen Geringverdiener
gegen Arbeitslose aus das
Milliardenvermögen der Superreichen
schützen und das sogenannte
Schonvermögen von Menschen die
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet haben in Frage
stellen das ist unwürdig insbesondere
mit dem Blick auf das C in ihrem Namen
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Britta Hasselmann die
Lebenswirklichkeit die
Lebenswirklichkeit ist dass die
Regelsätze jetzt 449 49 Euro betragen
ich erinnere daran dass im Januar die
Regelsätze um drei Euro erhöht worden
sind das war erbärmlich das war der
Staat der Koalition drei Euro so viel
kostet heute ein Stück Butter die
Inflation liegt bei zehn Prozent sie
hätten die Regelsätze schon im Sommer
mindestens um diese 53 Euro anheben
müssen jetzt laufen die Taschen übrig
fortschrittkoalition in der Realität ist
das eine Schnarch Koalition immer zu
spät und immer zu wenig das ist die
Realität meine Damen und Herren bei den
Energiepreisen Deckelung viel zu spät
Erhöhung der Regelsätze Inflation
verpennt jetzt ist November sie mit
ihrer briesigkeit haben Friedrich Merz
erst ermöglicht dass es die Wahrheit
meine Damen und Herren
wir wir erkennen ganz klar an wir
erkennen ganz klar an es gibt
Fortschritte Hubertus Heil hat das an
einem Beispiel eindringlich geschildert
Schüler Azubis studierende können
deutlich mehr behalten von ihren
Verdiensten dass es gut die zweijährige
Karenzzeit beim Wohnen sicherlich
positiv überhaupt keine Frage aber bei
allen Fortschritten bei allen
Fortschritten das Bürgergeld ist nicht
im ansatzarmutsfest
300 Euro bleiben Armut per Gesetz meine
Damen und Herren bedrückt sich man die
Inflation sind das 0,0 meine Damen und
Herren liebe Sozialdemokraten und
Sozialdemokraten was steht in eurem
Wahlprogramm die Regelsätze im neuen
Bürgergeld müssen zu einem Leben in
Würde ausreichen und zur
gesellschaftlichen Teilhabe befähigen
mit 53
was für ein Käse und was steht noch in
eurem Wahlprogramm das Bürgergeld muss
absichern dass eine kaputte
Waschmaschine und eine neue Winterjacke
nicht zu untragbaren Last werden das
leistet das Bürgergeld ausdrücklich
nicht das Bürgergeld ist zu wenig für
würde und auch zu wenig für eine neue
Waschmaschine meine Damen und Herren
Bürgergeld sind gut aber real ist das
eben keine Abkehr von Hartz IV das
System bleibt erhalten in der Substanz
ist es Hartz 5 meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von denen
die meinen die Regelsätze dürfen nicht
armutsfest sein und das Schonvermögen
müsste möglichst gering sein da wird
immer dann das Lohnabstandsgebot
angeführt wie absurd ist das denn wir
haben kein Problem mit zu hohen
Regelsätzen wir haben aber einen
millionenfaches Lohn und das wird dann
zu einem Rentenproblem im Verkauf einer
Pflege bei den Dienstleistungen sind die
Löhne schlicht zu niedrig die Löhne
müssen rauf und nicht die Leistung
politisch klein gerechnet werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie immer auch
das Kind heißen mag am 1 Januar müssen
die Sätze steigen und wir brauchen
schleunigst dann eine realistische
Neuberechnung die den Mensch die die
Menschen wirklich tatsächlich vor Armut
schützen und ein Leben in Würde
garantiert und in der Zwischenzeit da
brauchen wir monatliche Zuschläge wie
das in unserem Antrag steht das wäre
eine Brücke meine Damen und Herren und
der Union kann ich nur zurufen hören sie
mit ihrer Blockade auf kein
Verschiebebahnhof zum ersten siebten die
Lage ist für die Betroffenen vielfach
dramatisch nehmen Sie bitte diese
Menschen in den Blick herzlichen Dank
der Linksfraktion ihm wird jetzt folgen
Martin Rosemann der ist Arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
das Bürgergeld ist die größte
Sozialreform seit 20 Jahren wir
überwinden damit Hartz IV vor allem aber
ist das Bürgergeld die Antwort auf die
aktuellen Herausforderungen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt für einen Arbeitsmarkt der
gekennzeichnet ist durch
Arbeitskräftemangel nicht mehr durch
Massenarbeitslosigkeit und deshalb
passen wir das System der Grundsicherung
an die Herausforderungen der Zeit an
sechs grundsätzliche Veränderungen sind
dabei wesentlich erstens mehr Respekt
für Lebensleistungen
Karenzzeit bei der Vermögensanrechnung
macht eben den Unterschied zwischen
denen die immer gearbeitet haben und
sich was angespart haben und denen die
das nicht gemacht haben und nach ihrer
Rede Herr Gröhe kann ich nur feststellen
wir die Ampel sind für mehr Respekt für
Lebensleistung sie die Union sind
dagegen
zweitens
zweitens mehr Augenhöhe und damit einen
neuen Umgang zwischen dem Staat und den
Bürgern denn es geht um individuelle und
passgenaue Unterstützung wir wollen den
Staat als Partner der denjenigen hilft
die Hilfe braucht drittens mehr
Zielgenauigkeit beim fordern allen
gegenteiligen Behauptungen zum Trotz das
neue Bürgergeld sieht
Mitwirkungspflichten vor und auch
Sanktionen für diejenigen die sich
verweigern aber wer von Beginn an
mitwirkt und das sind die meisten wird
in Zukunft eben nicht mehr mit
Sanktionen bedroht und wer nicht
mitwirken kann beispielsweise wegen
einer psychischen Erkrankung der muss
unterstützt und nicht sanktioniert
werden
viertens
mehr fördern mit dem neuen Instrument
des umfassenden Coachings der
Entfristung des sozialen Arbeitsmarkts
der aufsuchenden Arbeit dem
Weiterbildungsgeld und dem
bürgergeldbonus sorgen wir für bessere
individuelle und passgenaue
Unterstützung 5 mehr Nachhaltigkeit wir
schaffen den vermittlungsvorgang ab und
setzen auf passgenaue und nachhaltige
Vermittlung in gute Arbeit wenn wir
Menschen einfach nur schnell in Arbeit
bringen wollen riskieren wir nämlich
dass die Arbeit auch genauso schnell
wieder abgebrochen wird deshalb setzen
wir auf zielgenaue Qualifizierung in
gute Arbeit
und
und schließlich sechstens mehr
Leistungsgerechtigkeit denn wir erhöhen
die Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten vor allem
für junge Leute die selbst die Erfahrung
machen sollen dass sich arbeiten lohnt
mit dem neuen Bürgergeld gilt nun erst
recht dass Arbeit den Unterschied macht
um
um all dies um all dies zu realisieren
entlasten wir die Jobcenter von
Bürokratie und wir werden den Haushalt
für die Jobcenter auch ausreichend
ausstatten aber
Haushaltsdebatte lieber Hermann Gröhe
ist nächste Woche nicht diese Woche und
in diesem Zusammenhang weiß ich nur mal
darauf hin dass ich zu der Liste der
Fake News nun noch hinzugefügt hat wir
hätten den Bundesrechnungshof nicht
gehört gestern im Ausschuss für Arbeit
und Soziales über eine Stunde
Bundesrechnungshof Liebe Hermann Gröhe
meine
Damen und Herren Herr Rosemann
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion ja bitte
lieber Herr Kollege Rosemann ihre
Kollegin Saskia esken und sie haben es
jetzt gerade auch selbst in ihrer Rede
bestätigt hat heute morgen gesagt wir
müssen nicht mehr so viel fordern weil
wir befinden uns ja an einer
vollbeschäftigungsphase erkennen Sie an
dass das Prinzip aus Fordern und Fördern
der letzten nahezu 20 Jahre zu einem
großartigen Erfolg auf unserem
Arbeitsmarkt geführt wurde die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen deutlich reduziert werden
konnte und weitere Frage was passiert
eigentlich wenn sie jetzt nicht mehr
fordern sondern nur noch fördern stellen
Sie sich darauf ein dass wir künftig
wieder mehr Arbeitslose haben vielen
Dank
ja Frau Schimke vielen Dank für die
Frage
erstens frage ich mich so bisschen was
mit ihren Ohren los ist denn sie haben
offensichtlich immer noch nicht
verstanden dass wir fördern und fördern
nicht abschaffen dass es weiterhin
Mitwirkungspflichten und Sanktionen gibt
und Fake News Entschuldigung werden
durch Wiederholung nicht wahrer Frau
Schimke zweitens
zweitens
zweitens ich finde es interessant ich
finde es interessant dass sie mit diesem
Redebeitrag noch mal deutlich gemacht
haben dass die Union die Debatten von
vor 20 Jahren führt während wir die
Debatten von heute und für morgen führen
nehmen Sie doch zur Kenntnis dass wir es
mit einer anderen Situation auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt zu tun haben und drittens
und drittens Frau Schimke ich bin für
Fördern und Fordern und ich bin auch
dafür dass ich Leute die sich diesen
Mitwirkungspflichten entziehen entziehen
obwohl sie mitwirken können dass die
auch mit den Konsequenzen zu rechnen
haben im Rahmen dessen was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht vorgibt genauso
steht es im Gesetz aber was ich Ihnen
auch sagen will das müssen sie
eigentlich wissen mit ihrem beruflichen
Hintergrund als Vertreterin der
Arbeitgeberverbände müssen sie doch
wissen dass kein Arbeitgeber jemanden
einstellt der sich nur deshalb bei ihnen
bewirbt weil ihm sonst Sanktionen drohen
es muss doch ein Mindestmaß an
Motivation geben und dafür müssen wir
sorgen
meine Damen und Herren ich danke den
Beschäftigten in den Jobcentern schon
heute für die Umsetzung dieser Reform
wir wissen dass das eine Herausforderung
darstellt aber wir bekommen viel
Zustimmung für diese Reform aus der
Praxis und weil hier schon wieder der
Brandbrief beschrieben wird ich habe den
Brandbrief gelesen der Vorsitzende der
personalrätevertreter wohnt in meinem
Wahlkreis ich bin in mit dem im
Austausch und ich lese seine Nachrichten
auf Twitter und ich kann Ihnen sagen
dass wir das in Kraft treten der
einzelnen Punkte des Gesetzes genau so
regeln wie die Personalräte der
Jobcenter des verlangt haben
wir haben uns
wir haben uns entschieden im übrigen
diese große Reform des Bürgergeldes auf
zwei Gesetze aufzuteilen um die
Jobcenter nicht zu überfordern deswegen
werden wir auch den zuführdienst noch
mal umfassend Regeln den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt weiterentwickeln und auch
andere Instrumente weiterentwickeln mit
einem zweiten Paket jetzt geht es aber
um das erste Paket und die Ampel hat
umfangreiche Änderungen am Gesetz
vorgenommen und geht dabei auch auf
Forderungen und Kritikpunkte aus dem
Bundesrat ein
wir stellen zum Beispiel klar dass die
vertrauenszeit erst zustande kommt wenn
ein kooperationsplan gemeinsam
erarbeitet wurde wir sorgen dafür dass
bereits genutzte Karenzzeiten
angerechnet werden wir sorgen dafür dass
in der Karenzzeit lediglich angemessene
Heizkosten übernommen werden und Umzüge
in teurere Wohnungen der Genehmigung
bedürfen nun hat es der Bundesrat haben
es die Länder in der Hand sich auch
ihrer Verantwortung zu stellen es liegt
jetzt an Ihnen ob zum ersten Januar die
dringend erforderliche Anhebung der
Regelsätze stattfindet ich fordere Sie
auf nehmen Sie diese Verantwortung wahr
Martin Rosemann für die SPD-Fraktion in
der Debatte zum bürgergeldgesetz Morgen
ist der 11.11 am 11.11 vor vier Jahren
hat die damalige SPD-Vorsitzende Andrea
Nahles beim debattenkämpft der SPD zum
ersten Mal in einer großen öffentlichen
Rede angekündigt dass die SPD Hartz IV
überwinden wolle das ist eine
sozialstaatsreform geben müssen also
endet heute ein vier Jahre dauernder
Prozess bis hin zum Bürgergeld vom Hartz
IV von ALG2 zum Bürgergeld Stefan
Stracke istanbold Arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion hier ist unsere
ausgestreckte Hand als Fraktion meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und ich
fordere Sie auf nehmen Sie diese
ausgestreckte fängt an zeigen sie
Verantwortung und sorgen Sie für
Sicherheit für diejenigen die das
tatsächlich ernsthaft gebrauchen und
benötigen und ich habe den Eindruck sie
wollen nicht Sicherheit und
Verlässlichkeit geben sondern sie wollen
dass als Faustpfand behalten für die
Durchsetzung ihres vermorgsten
Bürgergeld Gesetzes in diesem Werk und
das ist das Gegenteil von Verantwortung
Herr Minister
wir befürworten eine schnellere
Anpassung der Regelsätze an die
Teuerungsrate und gleichwohl bleibt
richtig Arbeit muss sich lohnen und das
sagen sie ja selber auch wir wollen das
Arbeit sich lohnt das Arbeit den
Unterschied macht und dann wenn man sich
die Vielzahl an Berechnungen da auch mal
anschaut dann zeigt sich in gewissen
Fallkonstellationen nicht die Arbeit
macht den Unterschied sondern die
ergänzende Sozialleistung macht den
Unterschied nämlich das Wohngeld oder
der Kinderzuschlag und wenn wir darauf
hinweisen dass hier Handlungsbedarf
besteht dann werden wir von ihnen
beschimpft wenn wir darauf hinweisen
dass wir das Steuerrecht an dieser
Stelle verändern müssen dann werden wir
von ihnen beschimpft allerdings ihr
eigener Kollege auf der Regierungsbank
Herr heilt nicht der
Bundesfinanzminister sagt zitiere ich
darf zitieren aus der Funken
Mediengruppe in den Zeitungen vom 29.10
Zitat von Christian Lindner wenn
Sozialleistungen wie der Regelsatz bei
der Grundsicherung automatisch an die
Inflation angepasst werden dann müssen
auch die arbeitenden Menschen einen
automatischen Ausgleich bekommen recht
hat er aber das ist nichts was zu
diffamieren gilt und deswegen bedarf ist
natürlich auch hier eines
veränderungsbedarfes an dieser Stelle
und
was wird denn jetzt besser erlauben sie
eine weitere Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkungen aus der Fraktion Bündnis
warum Herr starker meinen sie haben die
Vorsitzende von CSU und CDU Herr Söder
und der März nicht der Versuchung
widerstehen können und sind zu erzählen
es ist Unsinn zu behaupten dass ich
Arbeit nicht lohnt weil sich Arbeit
immer rechnet im Vergleich es ist Unsinn
Äpfel und Birnen vergleichen zu wollen
indem man so tut als würde bei den Hartz
IV beziehen der beziehungsweise
Bürgergeld beziehenden alles was an
sozialen Transfers möglich ist in
Anspruch genommen und den zum Vergleich
herangezogenen Niedriglöhner da
unterstellt man dass er das gerade nicht
tut das ist Unsinn es ist Unsinn so zu
tun
als gäbe es im Bürgergeld keine
Mitwirkungspflichten das Gegenteil ist
der Fall und zwar sowohl in der
vertrauenszeit als auch in der
kooperationszeit warum meinen sie haben
ihre Vorsitzenden darauf gesetzt Fake
News in die Welt zu setzen und den
Menschen ein X von U vor zwei Wochen zu
wollen was ist da los bei Ihnen
vielen herzlichen Dank Herr Kollege ich
glaube das gibt auch noch mal
Gelegenheit darauf einzugehen zum einen
machen wir es mal ganz ohne Streit
stehen immer einfach mal ein Beispiel
dass der DGB gerechnet hat das
entspricht ja auch ihre linken Seele
etwas mehr bei einem Paar von zwei
Kindern acht und zwölf Jahre alt ein
Verdienst von 38 Stunden Mindestlohn von
12 Euro der Vergleich der DGB sie können
das alles nachlesen alles ganz
transparent auf der dgb-seite Vergleich
des mit einem bürgergeldbezieher und es
verfügbare Einkommen bei den
bürgergeldbezieher im vergleichbarer
Situation liegt bei 2349 Euro bei
demjenigen der arbeitet bei
2050 Euro also
299 Euro weniger in der Tasche als ein
Hartz-IV-Empfänger
und wenn wir darauf hinweisen erst durch
die ergänzende Sozialleistung nämlich
das Wohngeld und den Kinderzuschlag in
Höhe von 817 Euro so wie es der DGB
eröffnet hat und berechnet hat das macht
dann das Plus von 500 Euro dann
unterstellen sie uns da und beschimpfen
uns in dem Fall weil eben nicht die
Arbeit den Unterschied macht sondern die
ergänzende Sozialleistung und das ist ja
auch der Grund warum der
Bundesarbeitsminister darauf hinweist
dass er das Kindergeld erhöht den
Kinderzuschlag erhöht der
Grundfreibetrag erhöht wird und vieles
mehr also das ist der Unterschied und
ein zweites weil sie das Thema
Sanktionen angesprochen haben auch hier
sie bleiben mit dem Bürgergeld Entwurf
weit hinter dem zurück was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht zulässt und sie
bleiben auch hinter dem zurück was
bislang Praxis des der
Bundesarbeitsagentur war ich will Ihnen
an dieser Stelle mal ein paar Beispiel
nennen beim den ersten halben Jahr
können Sie jegliche der sie müssen noch
stehen bleiben ich beantworte Ihre Frage
mit den Sanktionen
Sie bitte stehen bleiben beantwortet
immer noch die ihre Frage weil sie sagen
was das Thema Sanktionen angeht im
ersten halben Jahr im ersten halben Jahr
können Sie jegliches Vermittlungsangebot
jeglichen Deutschkurs jeglichen
Integrationskurs jegliche
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeit folgenlos
abbrechen oder nicht antreten das ist
ihre Politik hier atmet diese
Grundsicherung letztendlich den Geist
des bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen und
ein meldeversäumnis ja das ist im ersten
halben Jahr möglich zu sanktionieren
aber nach zweiten meldeversonnen also
sie haben einen freischuß in dem Bereich
eingeführt und auch bei den
Pflichtverletzungen übrigens bleiben sie
auch hier weil ich immer noch bei den
Sanktionen bin bei den
Pflichtverletzungen ich will bleiben sie
in Not dabei 20 Prozent bleiben sie
weithin weg und auch was die total
Verweigerer angeht das
bundesfassungsgericht hat gesagt
derjenige der sich beharrlich verweigert
der muss und kann auch total
sanktioniert werden davon machen Sie
keine Möglichkeit also von dem Anspruch
das was das bundesfassungsgericht an
Möglichkeiten eröffnet machen sie
weniger und damit ist es ein weniger am
fordern in diesem Bereich was das
Geld
tatsächlich macht Herr Stracke ich habe
auch wenn der Tag heute insgesamt lang
wird aber ich habe noch eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung aus
der SPD-Fraktion
ich freue mich ja
Herr Kollege Stracke ich würde gerne
darauf eingehen was sie in den letzten
Wochen vorgetragen haben zu der Frage ob
sich Arbeit lohnt und was sie heute
vorgetragen haben das ist nämlich sehr
interessant sie räumen ja immerhin ein
dass viele der Berechnungen die
Sozialleistungen der ergänzenden oder
auch aufstockenden Sozialleistungen
missachtet haben und deswegen zu
interessanten Ergebnissen gekommen sind
um es mal vorsichtig zu sagen was aber
jetzt meine Frage ist wenn Sie erkannt
haben dass nicht die Arbeit alleine und
der Arbeitslohn alleine ohne ergänzende
Sozialleistungen den Unterschied macht
wenn Sie das erkannt haben warum haben
Sie sich dann eine Erhöhung des
Mindestlohns auf 12 Euro verweigert und
warum Frau weigern sie sich auch einer
Erhöhung der Tarifbindung
wissen sie
das Thema Mindestlohn ist eine Debatte
wo wir dann auf achten müssen wie wir
das richtig machen gerade was die
Erhöhung auch des Mindestlohns in diesem
Bereich ist aber es ist ja interessant
dass sie ausschließlich als Antwort dann
finden dass wir arbeiten immer teurer
machen müssen gerade auch in anderen
Bereichen und damit weniger
Einstiegschancen in diesem Bereich und
deswegen ist es ja so richtig wenn der
Bundesfinanzminister eine anderen
Vorschlag unterbreitet nämlich dem
Bereich der Grundfreibeträge
entsprechend anzuheben und wenn wir
darauf hinweisen dass das genau der
richtige Ansatzpunkt ist in diesem
Bereich und nicht neue Barrieren
entstehen zu lassen dann werden wir von
ihnen beschimpft und das zeigt doch wie
heuchlerisch Sie unterwegs sind weil auf
ihrer eigenen Regierungsbank sie zur
anderen Lösungen kommen in diesem
Bereich und wenn wir darauf hinweisen
dass das genau die richtige Lösung ist
dann tun sie das nicht meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und was wird
denn jetzt tatsächlich besser durch das
durch das sie können gerne noch stehen
bleiben was wird denn besser durch das
Bürgergeld diese Frage stellt sich
beispielsweise die FDP in einem
inflationsinformationspapier der
Fraktion ich frage mich das auch was
eigentlich durch das Bürgergeld besser
wird aber interessant ist die Antwort
aus der Hängematte wird ein Sprungbrett
das muss man sich erst einmal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen
auf aus der Hängematte wird ein Sprung
Weg sie
differ wie neigen die in einer sozialen
Notlage sich befinden als Hängematte
meine sehr verehrten Damen
ungeheuerlicher
[Applaus]
Vorgaben es sind unsere Regierungszeit
geschafft sich herauszuarbeiten aus
Arbeitslosigkeit und einen festen
Arbeitsplatz in der Arbeitsgesellschaft
erreicht über 2 Millionen Menschen haben
Hartz IV als Sprungbrett benutzt und um
zurückzukommen in Arbeit das ist das
Gegenteil von einer Hängematte sie
diffamieren hier dieses System sie
diffamieren die Menschen in diesem
Bereich der eine großartige Leistung
erbracht haben das ist Respektlosigkeit
und da sieht man mal welchen Geist hier
in diesem Haus bei der Ampel tatsächlich
vorhanden ist und es ist auch respektlos
im übrigen gegenüber den Mitarbeitern in
den Jobcentern die tatkräftig hierbei
unterstützen dass diese Erfolg gelungen
ist und jetzt zu ihrem das was sie sich
rühmen nämlich die Veränderung der
Hinzuverdienstgrenzen
und die Verbesserungen dabei ich wundere
mich ja wenn man sagt naja wer eine AR
derjenige der einen Azubi Gehalt bekommt
der hat jetzt mehr davon als vorher das
ist richtig aber warum machen Sie denn
hier eine Grenze von 25 Jahren warum ist
denn derjenige der im Alter der
vielleicht eine Familie hat der sich
entscheiden muss geht er denn in
Ausbildung oder macht er denn
beispielsweise ein Aushilfsjob dass sie
da gerade nicht diese Verbesserungen für
diejenigen machen oder ein zweites sie
rühmen sich der Tatsache dass sie jetzt
zehn Cent mehr von einem verdienten Euro
in der Tasche haben nämlich die Bezieher
da sagt zu Recht des Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft das ist zu wenig
ambitioniert das ist zu wenig
ambitioniert das ist kein Anreiz eine
Tätigkeit mit einer Entlohnung über 1200
Euro letztendlich aufzunehmen das was
sie als Sprungbrett definieren damit
machen Leistungsbezieher tatsächlich
keine großen Sprünge wir brauchen
weniger aufstiegslyrik sondern
wirklichen Aufstieg für die Menschen
dafür sorgen Sie mit diesem Bürgergeld
nicht
Stefan Stracke war das Arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer Sprecher der CDU
CSU-Fraktion in einer Debatte über das
bürgergeldgesetz der auch drei Anträge
aus der Linksfraktion zugrunde liegen
und eine aus der afd-fraktion und wir
stellen fest quer durch die Reihen es
geht hier heute nicht ohne Polemik in
dieser Debatte die nächste Rednerin wird
sein Stefanie Effner aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen sie ist Mitglied
im Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales und
in diesem Ausschuss speziell zuständig
für das Thema Bürgergeld
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen wir führen hier eine
hochemotionale Debatte es wird Arroganz
vorgeworfen es werden Berechnungen in
den Raum geworfen die hinterher wieder
korrigiert werden müssen ich
entschuldige mich bei all den Menschen
in diesem Land die davon betroffen sind
denn die Debatte wird auf ihrem Rücken
ausgetragen über wen reden wir denn an
dieser Stelle über 60 Prozent der
Menschen die arbeitslos werden finden
innerhalb von einem Jahr wieder einen
Job die kommen also gar nicht in den
bürgergeldbezug weitere 20 Prozent der
Menschen haben nach zwei Jahren einen
Job und hier kommt jetzt der erste
Konflikt mit der Union wir sagen wir
wollen zwei Jahre Karenzzeit dass
Menschen zwei Jahre ihre Wohnung
behalten können sie haben einen
zukunftspapier von ihrer AG die es auf
ein Jahr begrenzt fragen wir uns doch
mal für welche Menschen macht das im
Endeffekt einen Unterschied
200.000 Menschen die wohlgemerkt an dem
Ende der von uns vorgeschlagenen
Karenzzeit wieder einen Job gefunden
haben den sie sagen wollen nein ihr
müsst umziehen und eure Wohnung auch
noch obwohl ihr am Ende dieser zwei
Jahre wieder eine wohl eine Arbeit haben
werden das ist eine Stadt so groß wie
Potsdam
die gleiche Debatte führen wir beim
Schonvermögen sie malen Bilder von
Menschen die in unheimlichen Reichtum
sich darin gefallen Bürgergeld zu
beziehen die zeittitelt heute Stütze für
reicher wie sieht denn die Realität aus
über 40 Prozent der Menschen in diesem
Land haben überhaupt keine Rücklagen
denn dann in dieser Debatte es geht um
die Menschen die zum Beispiel eine
Abfindung bekommen weil sie arbeitslos
werden es geht um die Menschen die
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet haben und sich
Rücklagen gebildet haben und denen sagen
wir schön dass ihr das alles getan habt
aber im übrigen die gleiche
Vermögensgrenze die sie in der Pandemie
selber eingeführt haben und die auch im
Wohngeld geht das ist zu viel und auch
die Entlastung der Jobcenter worum es
nämlich auch geht der Mitarbeitenden
dass sie nicht mit Bürokratie
beschäftigt sind an dieser Stelle auch
das lehnen sie ab
wir haben ein Sanktionen natürlich
weiterhin welche drin wir hätten davon
eine andere Vorstellung gehabt aber es
geht doch darum wie gehen wir mit der
übergroßen Mehrheit der Menschen im
bürgergeldbezug um sie schauen immer auf
die wenigen wo es Probleme gibt wir
sagen die allermeisten Menschen nämlich
97 Prozent wirken mit und arbeiten an
der Überwindung ihrer Situation und
genau die wollen wir nicht mehr
anlasslos bedrohen denn wir haben
Respekt vor diesen Menschen und das ist
unsere Aufgabe
Stefanie Effner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen ich kann noch mal einen
Punkt aufnehmen den Bärbel Bass die
Bundestagspräsidentin vorhin mal
Nebensatz gesagt hat der Tag wird lang
hat sie gesagt und sich damit bezogen
auf die Tagesordnung die heutige des
Deutschen Bundestages die ging vor
dieser Debatte ohnehin schon bis 2:59
Uhr also bis 3 Uhr in der Nacht da wird
sicherlich einiges zu Protokoll gegeben
aber den Abgeordneten steht hier noch
einiges ans an Arbeit ins Haus heute
Gerrit hui aus der afd-fraktion am
Montag haben wir von vielen
Sachverständigen in großer Deutlichkeit
gehört dass das Bürgergeld
voraussichtlich noch mehr Probleme
aufweisen wird als heute schon Hartz IV
und auch die Kritik des
Bundesrechnungshofs wird dadurch sehr
stark bestätigt der vor Ort Prüfung
durchgeführt hat und deswegen sehr gut
beurteilen kann was in den Jobcentern
funktioniert und was eben nicht und er
hat herausgefunden dass drei von vier
Jobcenter mit der Verwässerung und
Aufweichung der Sanktionsmöglichkeiten
große Probleme haben ich möchte mich
aber heute auf einen anderen neuen Punkt
konzentrieren nämlich den Entfall das
vermittlungsvorgangs dadurch erhofft
sich die ampelregierung dass eine
zusätzliche Qualifikation von
Langzeitarbeitslosen möglich wird und
damit eine bessere und nachhaltigere
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt ich
befürchte allerdings dass mit dieser
Maßnahme eher das Gegenteil erreicht
wird und wir stattdessen zusätzlich
Arbeitskräfte verlieren
Ausbildung und Weiterbildung waren
nämlich auch bisher schon möglich wurden
aber gerade von
Geringqualifizierten nur sehr selten
wahrgenommen und beim überwiegenden Teil
der Langzeitarbeitslosen handelt es sich
nun mal um Geringqualifizierten zwei
Drittel von ihnen verfügen über keinen
Berufsabschluss viele von ihnen haben
auch kein Schulabschluss und es gibt
nach wie vor viele funktionale
Analphabeten unter ihnen da wird
Ausbildung und Weiterbildung extrem
schwierig
über die Hälfte der Langzeitarbeitslosen
sind Flüchtlinge eine weitere große
Gruppe hat einen Migrationshintergrund
häufig treten deshalb zu den allgemeinen
Lernschwierigkeiten auch noch
Sprachschwierigkeiten hinzu wir haben es
hier also mit einem fulminanten kaum zu
lösende Problem zu tun
meine Damen und Herren die
Nachqualifizierung wird nach allem was
wir in Erfahrung bringen konnten nur in
wenigen Fällen wohl funktionieren häufig
werden sich nicht genügend Teilnehmer
für eine Bildungsmaßnahme befinden und
die die mitmachen hören sehr häufig sehr
schnell wieder auf das ist für alle
Seiten extrem frustrierend wenn es auch
aus Seiten der Langzeitarbeitslosen mit
einem zusätzlichen Bildungsgeld von
immerhin 150 Euro im Monat versüßt
werden soll
sie hören es nicht gerne aber Hartz IV
ist inzwischen unbeachteter Tatsache
dass wir natürlich auch viele deutsche
Langzeitarbeitslose haben aber Hartz IV
und damit auch zukünftiges Bürgergeld
ist in großem Teilen inzwischen zu einem
Migrationsproblem geworden
kommen halt
üben qualifizierte
und viele von diesen geringen
qualifizierten wären für
helferpositionen vermutlich durchaus
geeignet es gibt aber uns viele
Migranten die in anderen Jobs tätig sind
aber aus Hartz IV heraus funktioniert
das anscheinend gar nicht mehr das
konnten wir im Sommer sehr deutlich
beobachten als für die
koffertransporteure an den Flughafen
eigens neue Migranten eingeführt werden
sollten
offensichtlich gilt gerade für
Zuwanderer aus sehr armen Ländern dass
sie sich recht auskömmlichen unseren
Sozialsystemen bewegen können Liebe
ampelkollegen
sie sollten sich deswegen nichts
vormachen ihre große und sicherlich gut
gemeinte Qualifizierungsoffensive wird
kaum den gewünschten Erfolg haben und
deswegen spreche ich es noch mal aus das
Problem an der Wurzel zu packen bedeutet
die unkontrollierte Einwanderung zu
stoppen
[Applaus]
kein Probleme nicht haben können
dankeschön
aus der FDP-Fraktion er ist
passenderweise Sprecher für Bürgergeld
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen im Zentrum des
Bürgergeld stehts nicht wie immer wieder
behauptet wird mehr Lässigkeit im
Zentrum des Bürgergeld steht das
Leistungsprinzip und
Berufseinstiegschancen durch
Qualifizierung also die nachhaltige
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt das ist
das Zentrum des Bürgergeldes und wenn
man ein Beispiel nennen müsste ein
einziges Beispiel an dem man das
festmacht dann sind es Auszubildende die
in einer hartz-iv-bedarfsgemeinschaft
aufwachsen wenn die aktuell dort 800
Euro Ausbildungsvergütung haben dann
bleiben ihm faktisch nur 240 Euro der
Rest wird angerechnet das
Hartz-IV-System was sie verteidigen was
sie nicht verändert haben sagt diesen
jungen Menschen eine Ausbildung und
Arbeit lohnt sich nicht
jetzt ist es so beim Bürgergeld von 800
Euro dürfen die 6004 Euro behalten das
ist mehr als das 2,5 Bacher die
Botschaft des Sozialstaates ist klar es
lohnt sich zu arbeiten es lohnt sich
eine Ausbildung und wenn sie jetzt
kritisieren wie kann das denn sein dass
er überhaupt noch was angerechnet wird
das ist alles nur Aufstiegs Lyrik nein
das verändert bei jungen Menschen etwas
im Kopf es verändert die Botschaft und
wenn sie sagen wieso ist das zu wenig
wieso haben sie es in den letzten Jahren
nie angepasst wenn das doch eigentlich
eine Selbstverständlichkeit war weil es
ihn nicht um diese jungen Menschen geht
sondern es geht um eine Scheindebatte
und die Scheindebatte Herr Gröhe haben
wir erlebt sie haben gerade eben wieder
vorgeworfen den brandbeef der
Personalräte der Brand lief der
Personalräte kam zum ersten
Gesetzesentwurf wir haben den
Gesetzesentwurf angepasst das so dass
beim zum ersten ersten nur die
Regelsätze in Kraft treten die
Karenzzeit und die Bagatellgrenze auf
Wunsch der BA die BA wünscht sich dass
dieser Punkte zum ersten ersten Kraft
tritt alles andere wird nach hinten
verschoben die BA hat in der Anhörung
gesagt sie findet das total gut dass das
stattfindet sie hat gesagt sie braucht
diese Vorbereitungszeit und wünsche euch
dass der Bundesrat schnell zu einer
Entscheidung kommt weil eine Bacardi in
schaden würde ihr Kollege Stracke ist
dann zur Presse gegangen hat gesagt die
BA würde dem Vorschlag der CDU
unterstützen nur die Regelsätze zu
erhöhen und sie wiederholen das jetzt
gerade sogar noch in der Debatte das
sind das ist die Form von Fake News die
sie immer wieder vortragen
und jeder dieser Fake News zu entkräften
dauert länger als in die Welt setzen und
deswegen möchte ich noch einen zweiten
Punkt bringen wo sie ja vielleicht jetzt
mal auch in der Sache was kritisieren
sie kritisieren das schon Vermögen das
sei viel zu viel
unser Ansicht nach ist wer kurzfristig
ins SGB 2 reinrutscht weil er
beispielsweise gar keinen Anspruch auf
Arbeitslosengeld 1 hat selbstständiger
als Beispiel der sollte nicht sofort
sein Haus verkaufen müssen seine
Altersvorsorge aufbrauchen müssen und
sein Erspartes dann sagt der Kollege
witteka genau dann sagt der Kollege
Whittaker ist doch jetzt schon das
Altersvorsorge ausgenommen wird ist doch
jetzt schon der Fall ich sehe auch
nicken in ihrem rein gerade guckt man
aber genau ins Gesetz ist das nur die
staatlich geförderte Altersvorsorge es
ist nur Riester und rührup sobald sich
jemand entscheidet privat vorzusagen
vorvorzusorgen ist die nicht ausgenommen
und genau diese Feinheiten lassen die
jedes Mal bei jedem Argument weg und
schüren damit eine Debatte die es wo es
nicht um die Sache geht lassen Sie uns
um die Sache diskutieren wir sind für
private Altersvorsorge bei
Selbstständigen wir sind dafür dass sie
auch in Aktien investieren können und
das auch geschützt wird wenn Sie
kurzfristig reinkommen langfristig ist
es nicht möglich mit solchen
Vermögenswerten Bürgergeld zu beziehen
langfristig ist das nicht möglich das
verschweigen sie auch jedes Mal wenn es
um die Frage der Karenzzeit geht und
guckt man in ihrem Positionspapier der
cdu-arbeitsgruppe Arbeit und Soziales in
der Bundestagsfraktion noch wohl nicht
beschlossen worden super ist sogar
beschlossen worden da fordern sie selbst
diese schonvermögensgrenze dauerhaft das
ist sogar möglich mehr zu haben an schon
vor mögen als bei uns in verschiedenen
Fallbeispielen und deswegen ist die
Debatte nicht ehrlich sie wird nicht in
der Sache geführt sie wird unehrlich
geführt und deswegen es ist richtig dass
wir das Bürgergeld jetzt einführen und
ich würde mich freuen wir würden mehr in
der Sache diskutieren als mit falschen
Behauptungen ich freue mich dass sie
jetzt zum Glück jetzt auch mal langsam
die richtigen Berechnungen nehmen und
nicht mehr die der Jungen Freiheit weil
die waren lange genug auf der Seite der
CSU
Sprecher für Bürgergeld in der
FDP-Fraktion und hat verwiesen auf
Widersprüche zwischen Reben und
Positionspapieren der Unionsfraktion in
dieser Debatte es gibt ja hier schon
seit geraumer Zeit gegenseitige vorhalte
das mit falschen Zahlen agiert und
diskutiert werde Annika Klose ist die
nächste Rednerin aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Skandal Skandal das neue Bürgergeld soll
kommen doch kann es sein liebe
Kolleginnen von der Union dass das
Gespenst was sie zu sehen glauben in
Wahrheit nur ein Schattenbild an einer
Höhlenwand ist ich möchte etwas zur
Erhellung beitragen erstens
was ist mit dem Skandal der angeblich zu
hohen Schonvermögen mit dem Bürgergeld
wollen wir dafür sorgen dass Menschen
die lange gearbeitet haben nicht direkt
auch noch ihre Rücklagen und ihre
Wohnung verlieren müssen wenn sie gerade
auch schon ihren Job verloren haben
sondern wir schaffen
ihre geschontest um sich weiter
zu qualifornische aufgebraucht werden
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich kann den
Skandal nicht erkennen vor allem nicht
wenn wir von Menschen erwarten dass sie
bis 67 arbeiten sollen dann muss es das
auch mal möglich sein auch mal um zu
schulen ohne direkt alles zu verlieren
zweitens was ist mit den angeblich so
langen Karenzzeiten in den ersten zwei
Jahren sollen die Jobcenter noch nicht
alles bis ins Detail durchleuchten und
prüfen das ist schließlich ein
wahnsinniger wahnsinniger bürokratischer
Aufwand dabei kommen doch über 50% der
leistungsbezieherinnen und
Leistungsbezieher in den ersten zwei
Jahren auch wieder in Arbeit deswegen
sagen wir die Jobcenter sollen die
Wohnung und die privaten rücklehrlagen
erst nach dieser Schonfrist ganz genau
überprüfen das erleichtert nämlich allen
Beteiligten das Leben und schafft auch
leichtere Zukunft Zugänge in der
Krisenzeit auch hier ist der Skandal
ehrlich gesagt nicht zu erkennen und vor
zwei Jahren hat die Union da übrigens
auch noch zugestimmt und das genauso
gesehen
drittens Skandal wir wollen mehr
Menschen fördern statt nur zu fordern
wir schaffen mit dem Bürgergeld neue
Leistungen und Menschen die arbeitslos
sind besser bei der Arbeitsaufnahme zu
unterstützen denn es gibt
hunderttausende in diesem Land die trotz
der guten Lage auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
nicht vermittelt werden können klar man
kann natürlich auch alles so lassen wie
es ist und immer wieder dasselbe
versuchen und dann erwarten es natürlich
ein anderes Ergebnis dabei rauskommt
aber das hält ehrlich gesagt nicht nur
Albert Einstein für Wahnsinn also
erweitern wir mal den Instrumentenkasten
der Jobcenter und ehrlich gesagt kann
ich hier den Skandal ebenfalls nicht
erkennen ich freue mich ja wirklich dass
die Union mittlerweile erkannt hat dass
die Erhebung der Anhebung der
Regelsetzung 50 Euro kein Skandal ist
sondern bitter nötig aber jetzt nur das
zu machen und alles andere zu lassen ist
halt leider auch deutlich zu kurz
gesprungen und da ich jetzt mal vermute
dass sie das mir nicht glauben werden
möchte ich noch mal ein paar Leute
zitieren sehen sie sonst immer gerne
glauben erstens vom katholischen Büro
sagt die politischen Parteien sollten
den Weg für das Bürgergeld zügig frei
machen zweitens der Präsident der
Diakonie lässt sich zitieren dass ihre
Lösung nur die Regelsätze zu erhöhen ein
ganz schlechten Kompromiss sei und eine
überflüssige ideologische Debatte
geführt wird drittens die Caritas
twittert der fok
US der ist jetzt ganz dringend kommen
Liebe Christdemokraten weniger
Schattentheater mehr Erleuchtung die
Kirchen sind in dieser Frage ein guter
Kompass bitte besinnen sie sich vielen
Dank
mit einem Appell in die Unionsfraktion
und wenn wir hier mal in das Plenum des
Deutschen Bundestags schauen dann sehen
sie dass die reihen sich doch jetzt
deutlich füllen in gut nach 10 Minuten
wenn wir es uns jetzt nicht völlig
verrechnet damals 10 12 Minuten wird dir
die erste namentliche Abstimmung
aufgerufen werden es werden weitere
folgen und wie das dann abläuft und
worum es da im Detail geht das erkläre
ich Ihnen gleich jetzt hören wir erstmal
Kai Whittaker aus der Unionsfraktion
wir streiten zu Recht darüber ob das
schon Vermögen zu hoch die Karenzzeiten
zu lang und die Leistungskürzungen
zulass sind sie als Ampel wollen das
fordern möglichst abschaffen wir wollen
es erhalten das ist weder Hetze noch
Populismus es ist schlicht und
ergreifend unsere politische Auffassung
und die einer überwiegenden Mehrheit der
Menschen in diesem Land
die Deutschen sind in überwältigender
Mehrheit bereit Menschen in Not zu
helfen aber sie erwarten auch dass jeder
alles dafür tut aus dieser Hilfe so
schnell wie möglich wieder
herauszukommen und damit bin ich beim
Herrn dieser Debatte was ist eigentlich
das Ziel dieses bürgergeldgesetzes wann
ist dieses Gesetz eigentlich ein Erfolg
und mir ist aufgefallen kein einziger
von ihnen hatte den Mut sich hier
hinzustellen und zu sagen wir wollen die
Zahl der Langzeitarbeitslosen halbieren
in den nächsten drei Jahren
die SPD ist froh dass der Name Hartz IV
ein bisschen weniger das der Name hat
hier weg ist und jetzt Bürgergeld heißt
die Grünen finden sich damit ab dass es
ein bisschen billiger Leistungskürzungen
gibt und die FDP ist glücklich darüber
dass man ein bisschen mehr
hinzuverdienen können das ist
ambitionslos beim fördern wäre deutlich
mehr drin gewesen für die Arbeit suchen
Chance vertan und das obwohl wir zwei
Millionen offene Stellen haben 500.000
neue Jobs jedes Jahr neuer
Beschäftigungsrekord mit über 45
Millionen Beschäftigten und gleichzeitig
fällt ihnen fast nichts ein wie man
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen wieder in
Arbeit bringen dabei müsste genau das
das Herzstück einer Reform sein meine
Damen und Herren
haben die Mitarbeiter einen Jobcenter
mehr Zeit um sich um Langzeitarbeitslose
zu kümmern nein weil sie jetzt ständig
gucken müssen ob Ihre Kunden noch
vertrauenszeit genießt oder schon raus
ist aus der kooperationszeit haben die
Mitarbeiter mehr Geld um
Arbeitsmaßnahmen zu bezahlen nein sie
streichen die 600 Millionen Euro
verbessern sie die Beratungsqualität wie
ist die Bundesagentur für Arbeit anmahnt
nein gibt es vom Jobcenter durchgeführte
Sprachen und Integrationskurse mit
Kinderbetreuung damit gerade
ausländische Frauen eine Chance bekommen
nein machen sie es älteren Menschen ohne
Berufsabschluss attraktiver und leichter
eine Berufsausbildung zu machen nein all
diese Punkte wären notwendig denn wir
müssen beim fördern besser werden meine
Damen und Herren
und angesichts dessen ist es kein Wunder
dass kein einziger Arbeitsmarktexperte
bis heute gesagt hat dass dieses Gesetz
zu deutlich weniger Arbeitslosen führen
wird ein Satz zum Schluss wir haben die
Tag über heftig über dieses Gesetz
gestritten und man mag dieses Gesetz für
politisch falsch oder richtig halten
aber es hat mich schon entsetzt das SPD
Grüne und auch FDP nicht davor
zurückgeschreckt sind uns als Union Hass
und Hetze Populismus ja sogar ein
schlechtes Menschenbild zu unterstellen
bei aller Unterschiedlichkeit wenn wir
anfangen uns gegenseitig zu besichtigen
aus niederen Beweggründen oder in
schlechter Absicht Politik gegenüber den
Menschen zu betreiben dann legen Sie die
Axt an unsere demokratischen
Institutionen nicht die Lautstärke nicht
die Moral nicht das sind ins Recht
setzen entscheidet hier sondern die
demokratische Debatte das Abwägen von
Argumenten und die Einsicht immer nur
die zweitbeste Lösung hier zu
beschließen vielen Dank
Fraktion appelliert an eine faire
Debatte rund ums Thema Bürgergeld und
wir hören dazu jetzt Beate Müller
Gemecker aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen sie ist Mitglied im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales
zeitlich begründet sein und darf in
davon hat sich die Union bei Bürgergeld
gründlich verabschiedet sie haben eine
unsägliche Kampagne gestartet mit dem
sie Menschen mit kleinem Einkommen gegen
Erwerbslose ausspielen sie tun sie als
ob sich die Menschen bewusst und gezielt
in der Grundsicherung einrichten das ist
einfach nur billige Polemik das macht
was mit den Menschen die davon betroffen
sind hören Sie endlich damit auf
und die Union und hermitiker gerade
wieder behauptet ja immer beim fördern
wäre mehr drin gewesen das ist quatsch
das Gegenteil ist der Fall der neue
kooperationsplan wird gleich nach
Antragsstellung intensiv und gemeinsam
erarbeitet wir schaffen den
vermittlungsvorgang ab und ermöglichen
damit Unterstützung die wirklich zu den
Menschen passt besonders wir machen ein
ganzheitliches Coaching und besonders
junge Menschen sollen stärker vor
während und nach der Ausbildung
begleitet werden das war uns Grün in den
Verhandlungen ein besonderes Anliegen
und außerdem und außerdem schaffen wir
die außerdem entfristen wir den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt und das alles zeigt
natürlich kümmern wir uns um die
Menschen das fördern wird besser
und zentrales
und zentrales Thema ist die
Qualifizierung die Zahl der
abschlussbezogenen
Weiterbildungsmaßnahmen sind gering
obwohl die Mehrheit der
Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen kein
Berufsabschluss hat und das genau das
wollen wir ändern und deshalb stärken
wir die Qualifizierung mit einem
Weiterbildungsgeld mit einem
bürgergeldbonus damit eben Integration
in Arbeit besser gelingt die Union
interessiert das kein bisschen sie will
diese Verbesserungen blockieren und beim
Thema Qualifizierung ist das nicht
nachvollziehbar und auch nicht
akzeptabel
und um wen geht es hier eigentlich wenn
wir über das Bürgergeld reden und auch
das muss mal wohl für die Union geklärt
werden das sind rund zwei Millionen
Kinder und Jugendlichen fast zwei
Drittel der Erwerbsfähigen Menschen sind
gar nicht arbeitslos sie arbeiten und
stocken ihre niedrigen Lohn auf sie
pflegen Angehörige sie betreuen kleine
Kinder viele haben gesundheitliche
Einschränkungen und ich sage es ganz
deutlich niemand hat das Recht diese
Menschen zu stigmatisieren
das machen sie Tag für Tag die einen
brauchen einfach bessere Löhne und die
anderen brauchen Unterstützung
Qualifizierung und des soziale Teilhabe
und alle brauchen neue Chancen und
Perspektiven und genau das gehen wir an
mit dem neuen Bürgergeld mit einem
Perspektivwechsel bei der
Arbeitsförderung und wenn sie die Union
endlich mal nicht ideologisch sondern
fachlich auf das Gesetz schauen würden
dann würden sie auch die Verbesserung
sehen da bin ich mir ganz sicher vielen
Dank
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
war die drittletzte Rednerin in der
Debatte zum bürgergeldgesetz und zu den
Anträgen die zu diesem Thema hier im
Plenum vorliegen und dann gibt es hier
eine Reihe von Abstimmungen das werden
wir uns gleich mal von der
Bundestagspräsidentin erläutern lassen
zunächst aber Mark via das Haus der
Unionsfraktion
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das den beiden als Vorsitzender der SPD
unseren Fraktionsvorsitzenden mit Donald
Trump vergleicht und ihm Fake News und
Spaltung vorwirft das ist nicht nur
unverschämt sondern selbst spalterisch
und ein Tiefpunkt jeglicher
demokratischer und inhaltlicher Debatte
meine Damen und Herren
die ampelregierung ist mit großen
Ankündigungen und selfies gestartet
spätestens jetzt müssten sie allerdings
feststellen dass Regieren in
Krisenzeiten bedeutet Kompromisse zu
machen pragmatisch statt ideologisch zu
handeln doch sie machen einfach weiter
als nichts gewesen wäre heute wollen wir
ein rein ideologisches Bürgergeld gegen
jede fachliche Kritik verabschieden es
ist nicht nur die Union die ihr
Bürgergeld kritisiert der
Bundesrechnungshof der Landkreistag die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit die Jobcenter
Personalräte das Handwerk die
arbeitergeberverbände und eine Vielzahl
von Arbeitsmarktexperten diese Kritik
können sie doch nicht einfach
ignorieren Liebe Ampel
statt immer nur statt immer nur über
Kritik zu schimpfen wäre es an der Zeit
eigene Vorhaben zu überprüfen und zu
hinterfragen was wir derzeit erleben ist
ein stures Festhalten an
Koalitionsvereinbarungen mit der
Einführung des Bürgergeld vollzieht die
Bundesregierung eine Rolle rückwärts für
unseren Arbeitsmarkt und verabschiedet
sich vom erfolgreichen Prinzip von
fördern und fördern
fest steht meine Damen und Herren statt
von Problemlösungen ist die
Arbeitsmarktpolitik der Bundesregierung
geprägt von sozialdemokratischer
Vergangenheitsbewältigung viel Liebe
Ampel schaffen Hartz IV ab und mit der
sechs monatigen vertrauenszeit starten
Sie in ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen und das wollen wir nicht
als Union wollen wir keinen Menschen
aufgeben wir wollen dass Menschen
schnell in Arbeit wiederkommen und in
das gesellschaftliche Leben integriert
werden und mit dem bürgergeldgesetz
machen Sie genau den falschen Ansatz
meine Damen und Herren so geht es nicht
aus unserer Sicht beschränken sie mit
ihren Handlungsspielräumen die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Jobcentern und das kritisieren wir meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Ampel genau das kritisieren wir und
nicht die Erhöhung von den Hartz
iv-sätzen wir fordern die heute auf
stimmen Sie mit uns mit der Erhöhung der
Sätze von 53 Euro zum ersten Januar und
kommen Sie zurück mit uns an den
Verhandlungstisch wir reichen die Hand
wir haben ein Konzept lassen wir uns
darüber verhandeln aber das
bürgergeldgesetz lehnen wir heute ab
sagt mag biaraz aus der Unionsfraktion
der hier auch noch mal auf die
gegenseitigen teilweise auch
grenzwertigen Vorwürfe gegeneinander in
dieser Debatte verwiesen hat Jens Park
ist der letzte Redner SPD-Fraktion
Berichterstatter für diesen
Bereich insbesondere für das Bürgergeld
um wen geht es eigentlich bei dieser
Debatte
ich habe es ja schon der letzten Debatte
bei der ersten gesagt ich bin Kind des
Ruhrgebiets
und ich weiß was es heißt für Menschen
ihren Job verlieren Strukturwandel
Zechenschließung Werkschließung bei
Thyssen auf einmal waren tausende
Menschen arbeitslos die vorher nie daran
gedacht hätten dass sie arbeitslos
werden und damit das Ruhrgebiet ja nicht
allein
Ostdeutschland gibt es ganz ähnliche
Erfahrungen nach der Wende irgendein
Neumarkt Unternehmen geschlossen und
plötzlich waren Menschen arbeitslos
deshalb ist in Artikel 20 unseres
Grundgesetzes das Sozialstaatsprinzip so
wichtig das Bekenntnis zum Sozialstaat
ist ein Versprechen an uns alle ein
Versprechen das heißt wenn du deine
Arbeit verlierst lassen wir dich nicht
fallen und dieses Versprechen auch an
die arbeitende Mittel dieser
Gesellschaft werden wir hier und heute
mit der einführungs-
wir haben hier viel gehört zum Thema
Arbeit wir haben gehört Arbeit würde
sich nicht mehr lohnen und ja als
Sozialdemokratin und Sozialdemokraten
wissen wir dass das Problem auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt gibt aber die Probleme sind
auch der niedrigste und Sektor schlechte
Bezahlung miese Arbeitsbedingungen und
deswegen ist umso unredlicher dass die
Union sich dem Mindestlohn verweigert
hat und wir laden Sie einen kämpfen Sie
mit uns wie das gesagt hat für bessere
Tarifbindung und wir tun was auch
deswegen schaffen wir den
vermittlungsvorgang ab die Abschaffung
des vermittlungsfonds ist eine Kampf
Anlage an den niedrigen Sektor in diesem
Land keine Vermittlung Mensch schlechte
Jobs wenn es eine langfristige
Perspektive durchaus im Weiterbildung
gibt Ausbildung statt ausgeschoben
Perspektive statt Prekariat das ist die
neue Stoßrichtung des Bürgergeldes und
um wen geht es eigentlich ich sage Ihnen
ich bin mir ganz sicher heute hören auch
sehr aufmerksam zum Beispiel die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiterinnen
von Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof zu
die haben den letzten Jahren geschuftet
um den Konzern zu retten und über die
Runden zu kommen trotzdem droht jetzt
vielleicht unverschuldet wegen
Managementfehlern die Arbeitslosigkeit
und trotzdem obwohl sie sich Mühe
gegeben haben hart gearbeitet haben
brauchen Sie vielleicht Unterstützung
und deshalb schaffen wir mit dem
Bürgergeld ein Sozialstaat der die
arbeitende Mitte nicht vergisst ein
Sozialstaat der mit Schonvermögen und
Karenzzeit die Lebensleistung dieser
Menschen anerkennt und das ist der
notwendige Kulturwandel
und trotzdem
möchte die Union wir auch schon beim
Mindestlohn diesem Gesetz nicht
zustimmen trotzdem wollen sie es
blockieren und verzögern Herr Gröhe
sprachfehlerliste dies ab heute gibt wo
dann steht wer zugestimmt hat und wer
nicht ich sage Ihnen diese Liste fällt
auf sie zurück und deswegen appelliere
ich an sie appelliere an Sie übernehmen
sie Verantwortung für die menschlichen
Land für den Sozialstaat stimmen Sie zu
und sorgen Sie auch dazu dass ihre
länders im Bundesrat tun herzlichen Dank
Jens peik aus der SPD-Fraktion ist schon
ein Schritt weiter denn der Bundesrat
wird am kommenden Montag wahrscheinlich
schon ein erstes Mal auf dieses Gesetz
gucken und dann möglicherweise ein
Vermittlungsausschuss tätig werden
lassen Bärbel Bass jetzt mit dem
weiteren Prozedere
zum abstimmungsverlauf geben wir werden
jetzt gleich über einen Teil des
Gesetzentwurfes in der zweiten Beratung
namentlich abstimmen
hierfür haben sie ca 10 Minuten Zeit
nach Schließung dieser namentlichen
Abstimmung folgen drei
einfache Abstimmungen danach werde ich
die Sitzung bis zur Bekanntgabe des
Ergebnisses unterbrechen im Anschluss
daran folgt die namentliche
Schlussabstimmung für die wiederum ca 10
Minuten vorgesehen sind danach wird die
Sitzung für die Auszählung erneut
unterbrochen wenn ich dieses Ergebnis
bekannt gegeben haben werde ich über die
Beschlussempfehlung zu einem Antrag der
Fraktion DIE LINKE ebenfalls namentlich
abstimmen diese namentliche Abstimmung
läuft dann parallel zur Aussprache zur
Zusatzpunkt 4 für diese dritte
namentliche Abstimmung haben sie dann 30
Minuten Zeit
das Zeitfenster für die beiden ersten
namentlichen Abstimmung beträgt jeweils
zehn Minuten um einen zusammenhängenden
Abschluss des laufenden
Tagesordnungspunktes einigermaßen zu
gewährleisten ab der dritten
namentlichen Abstimmung sind für heute
jeweils 30 Minuten vorgesehen nicht
zuletzt im Hinblick auf parallele
Beratung in einigen Gremien insbesondere
im Haushaltsausschuss
wir kommen jetzt zur Abstimmung über den
von der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderungen des zweiten
Buches des Sozialgesetzbuches und
anderer Gesetze Einführung eines
Bürgergeldes hierzu liegt mehr eine
Erklärung nach Paragraph 31 unserer
Geschäftsordnung vor
der Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.360 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksachen
3.873 und
4.226 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
die Fraktion der cdu/csu hat beantragt
über den Gesetzentwurf in der
ausschussfassung getrennt abzustimmen
und zwar zum einen über die Artikel 5
Nummer 1F Nummer 5 Nummer 15 Nummer 17
Nummer 18
das sind die Paragraphen 28a 143 des 12
Buches Sozialgesetzbuch Fortschreibung
des Regelbedarfs der regelbedarfsstufen
und zum anderen über den Gesetzentwurf
im übrigen
ich rufe zunächst auf
die Artikel den Artikel 5 Nummer 1 f
Nummer 5 Nummer 15 Nummer 17 Nummer 18
in der ausschussfassung die Fraktion der
cdu/csu hat namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt die Abstimmung erfolgt in der
westlobby sie haben zu Abgabe ihrer
Stimme nach Eröffnung der Abstimmung ca
10 Minuten Zeit ich bitte jetzt die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer die
vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen das ist
erfolgt wie ich sehe
dann eröffne ich hiermit für zehn
Minuten die namentliche Abstimmung
so jetzt haben wir Ende der namentlichen
Abstimmung werde ich ihnen dann
rechtzeitig noch bekannt geben
so jetzt geht das große Gewusel hier los
wie man sie nicht nur hier im Saal
sondern auch in der westlobby also auf
den Gängen rund um den Plenarsaal wo die
abstimmungsurnen bereits bereitstehen
für die Abgeordneten können wir uns
sicherlich auch angucken da werden jetzt
also die Abgeordneten ihr Votum abgeben
für einen Teil des bürgergeldgesetzes
und sie haben sicherlich mitbekommen was
Bärbel Burst die Bundestagspräsidentin
hier eben aufgerufen hat jetzt geht es
ausschließlich um den Bereich in diesem
bürgergeldgesetz der sich mit den
sogenannten Regelsätzen beschäftigt also
mit der Erhöhung
dessen der einzelnen der einzelnen Sätze
der Erhöhung dessen was jetzt unter ALG2
Hartz IV in der Regel läuft die Anhebung
um rund 50 Euro für einzelne Personen
das ist ja dann in anderen Bereichen
dann noch mal weiter ausdifferenziert
und das ist jetzt Parteipolitik was hier
passiert denn die Ampelkoalition wird
einer separaten und ausschließlich auf
diesen Regeln setzen
basierenden Abstimmungen natürlich nicht
zustimmen sie möchte das ganze Gesetz
durchbringen deswegen wird es hier
mutmaßlich einen Teil Erfolg geben für
die Unionsfraktion und da wird man der
Koalition vorhalten sie wollen noch
nicht einmal jedes die Regelsätze erhöht
werden das ist Politik ob das schlau ist
ist eine andere Frage aber ist dient
hier sicherlich auch noch mal zur
Polarisierung innerhalb dieser Debatte
die ohnehin ein klein wenig polarisiert
geführt worden ist in der vergangenen
etwas mehr als einen Stunde diese
Abstimmung läuft jetzt sie sehen
hochbetriebe in der Lobby habe ich eben
in auch schon gesagt der Saal ist gerade
vergleichsweise leer das ganze wird gut
zehn Minuten dauern wir nutzen die
Gelegenheit um uns einzelne Teile der
heutigen Debatte noch einmal anzusehen
und den argumentationsaustausch den es
da gegeben hat und wir beginnen gleich
ganz vorne um ungefähr 9:15 Uhr trat sie
zunächst der Bundesarbeitsminister
Hubert zum Teil ans Rednerpult und ihm
folgte dann Hermann Gröhe
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion mit seinen Argumenten in
dieser Watte aber wir beginnen während
wir noch die Bilder sehen aus der Lobby
wo auch schon ein Teil der Abstimmung
stattgefunden hat das geht ja schnell
zum Kärtchen einzuwerfen für ja oder
nein oder auch Enthaltung also während
wir das noch sehen jetzt erstmal der
Blick auf den Morgen und es beginnt
Hubertus Heil
das Bürger
Geld man ist die größte
sozialstaatsreform seit 20 Jahren wir
verfolgen als Bundesregierung als
Koalition damit vor allen Dingen zwei
Ziele ja es geht darum dass Menschen die
in existenzielle Not geraten sind
verlässlich und so unbürokratisch wie
möglich abgesichert werden aber das
reicht uns nicht wir wollen nicht nur
Schutz geben in Zeiten der Not wir
wollen Chancen auf den selbstbestimmtes
Leben schaffen ich habe es eben am
Beispiel dieses Mannes am sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt beschrieben aber wir sagen
das auch mit Blick auf die Realität der
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit in Deutschland
wenn es so ist dass zwei Drittel der
Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen heute kein
abgeschlossenen Berufsabschluss haben
und sie im alten Hartz-IV-System dann
hin und wieder vielleicht mal in
Hilfstätigkeiten vermittelt werden aber
das Jobcenter sie nach ein paar Monaten
wiedersieht und sie nicht dauerhaft
nachhaltig in Arbeit vermittelt werden
dann ist im System was falsch mit dem
Bürgergeld ändern wir das wir schaffen
die Chance dass Menschen nicht in
Hilfstätigkeiten vermittelt werden
müssen sondern ein Berufsabschluss
nachholen können um dauerhaft und Arbeit
zu sein dass es auch ein Beitrag für
für den Bürgergeld reagieren wir auf
zwei fundamentale Veränderungen erstens
ist der Arbeitsmarkt heute ein völlig
anderer als vor 20 Jahren damals hatten
wir Massenarbeitslosigkeit heute in
vielen Bereichen Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel und zweitens ist es
wichtig aus den Erfahrungen der Krisen
der letzten Jahre auch der aktuellen
Krise zu lernen wenn es darum geht für
weniger Bürokratie im System und für
mehr Respekt für die Menschen zu sorgen
für Notlagen meine Damen und Herren
brauchen wir Lösungen die funktionieren
so unbürokratisch und so
bürgerfreundlich wie möglich wir sorgen
mit den Bürgergeld dafür dass wir
überflüssige Bürokratien in den
Jobcentern abbauen damit die
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeiter in der
Jobcenter die übrigens eine
hervorragende Arbeit leisten tatsächlich
sich auf das Wesentliche konzentrieren
können ein Beispiel ist das was die
Jobcenter immer gefordert haben zum
Beispiel eine Bagatellgrenze für
Kleinstbeträge wo Menschen mit
Bescheiden belästigten überzogen werden
dann lohnt weder Aufwand noch nutzen das
schaffen wir ab
vor allen Dingen meine Damen und Herren
aber sorgen wir für angemessenen Schutz
ein wichtiger Teil der Reform ist die
Erhöhung des Regelsatzes es geht darum
dass das Bürgergeld was die Erhöhung und
Anpassung der Regelsätze betrifft der
Inflationsentwicklung zukünftig nicht
mehr hinterherlaufen das ist gerade
jetzt besonders wichtig aber ich sage
auch klar und deutlich damit kann es
nicht getan sein die Qualität eines
Sozialstaats bemisst sich nicht allein
an der Höhe des sozialen Transfers
sondern die Qualität ist Sozialstaats
bemisst sich vor allen Dingen daran wie
sehr er in der Lage ist Menschen zu
einem selbstbestimmten Leben am Arbeit
zu bringen und ich sage es noch mal ein
Beispiel des Mannes den ich eingangs
genannt habe der hat mir erzählt was er
in den 15 Jahren erlebt hat wie er sich
die fingerbund geschrieben hat wie ihm
die Decke auf den Kopf gefallen ist und
dem Mann geht es heute besser in Arbeit
er sagt ich fühle mich wertgeschätzt ich
leiste was ich habe Kolleginnen Kollegen
meine Damen und Herren für die Mehrheit
der Menschen in Deutschland ist Arbeit
mehr als Broterwerb es ist Geld
verdienen aber es ist Teilhabe am
gesellschaftlichen Leben und damit
sorgen wir auch mit Bürgergeld dafür das
Leistungssystem
und wir setzen Anreize ein
Berufsabschluss nachzuholen ermöglichen
das nicht nur denn wer das einmal bei
Menschen erlebt hat die ein
Berufsabschluss verpasst haben die sich
dann wieder aufrappeln das ist sehr
anstrengend und wir wollen das Leistung
zielt und das auch mit finanziellen
Anreizen belohnt wird mit dem
Weiterbildungsgeld wir werden dafür
sorgen und da bin ich den
koalitionsfraktion sehr dankbar dass wir
uns darauf verständigt haben dass wir
Zuverdienstgrenzen im Bürgergeld erhöhen
damit Leistung sich lohnt das war nicht
nur ein Anliegen der FDP aber die FDP
hat sich besonders dafür eingesetzt ganz
herzlichen Dank dafür
und jetzt meine Damen und Herren muss
ich an die Adresse der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion mal meiner
Verwunderung Ausdruck bringen dass sie
heute den Antrag stellen dass nur der
Regelsatz erhöht wird wenn sie
wochenlang rumlaufen und sagen mit den
Bürgergeld lohnt sich Arbeit nicht mehr
und gleichzeitig nur den Regelsatz
erhöhen dann ist ein gewisser logischer
Bruch um es ganz deutlich zu sagen
denn Arbeit muss ein Unterschied machen
arbeit muss sich lohnen in Deutschland
und dafür sorgt die Koalition deshalb
haben wir den Mindestlohn erhöht meine
Damen und Herren auf 12 Euro und die
cdu/csu hat nicht mitgestimmt
deshalb kämpfen wir für mehr
Tarifbindung und brauchen auch da noch
ein bisschen Unterstützung kann die
Union sich auch verdient machen deshalb
haben wir das Wohngeld heute auf der
Tagesordnung gerade in diesen Zeiten
deshalb haben wir Beiträge und Steuern
für Geringverdiener gesorgt den Arbeit
müssen Unterschied machen aber in diesen
Zeiten in denen die gesellschaftliche
Stimmung angespannt ist aufgrund der
Krise werden und dürfen keine
demokratischen Demokraten zulassen das
geringverdienende Menschen gegen
bedürftige Menschen ausgespielt werden
wir müssen die gesamte Gesellschaft im
Blick haben und dieses Land
zusammenhalten es ist völlig verfehlt
dass sie in der Bereich der Integration
in Arbeit 600 Millionen Euro kürzen
wollen tun sie doch nicht so als hilft
ein neuer Name wenn sie beim Geld für
die Jobcenter kürzen für uns als Union
war stets klar Vorfahrt für Vermittlung
wir halten am fordern fest aber wir
müssen beim fördern besser werden wir
wollen nicht das alles so bleibt wie sie
es permanent unterstellen
heute verweigern sie jede sachliche
Debatte über die grundsätzlichen
Webfehler ihres Gesetzes ich dachte
zunächst da sei die ampelangst vor
Argumenten inzwischen weiß ich sie haben
sogar vor unseren fragenangst es ist
doch ungeheuerlich dass sie es der
Opposition verweigern dem
Bundesrechnungshof in einer Anhörung
dieses Parlaments zu befragen eine
Institution der das Grundgesetz
richterliche Unabhängigkeit zuschreibt
und sie wollen diese Antworten nicht im
Parlament hören unglaublich
glauben Sie eigentlich im Ernst glauben
Sie im Ernst die Arroganz der Mehrheit
im Bundestag erhöht die Chancen auf eine
Mehrheit im Bundesrat wer empfiehlt ihn
eigentlich so absurde Strategien ist
doch unglaublich ja die Zeit wird knapp
wir wollen am 1 Januar bessere
Bedingungen für die Menschen die
langzeitarbeitslos sind aber der
kabinettszeitplan ist der
kabinettszeitplan der Ampel der
parlamentszeitplan ist der
parlamentszeitplan der Ampel wir haben
zu keiner Zeit irgendetwas verzögert im
Gegenteil es waren die
arbeitsministerinnen und Minister der
Union die vor einer Woche an Sie als
Fraktionen der Ampel geschrieben haben
um welche grundsätzlichen Bedenken es
ging wir wollten uns ein
Vermittlungsverfahren ersparen wir
wollten Ihnen die Gelegenheit geben sich
zu korrigieren Sie haben die ungenutzt
verstreichen lassen
und trotz aller persönlichen
Herabsetzungen sei mal darauf
hingewiesen die Personalräte der
Jobcenter drängen auf eine Verschiebung
sie schreiben lesen Sie den Brandbrief
sie drängen darauf
sie nein ich weiß dass sie das Herr dürr
also im Schulhof gilt verbrüllt hat
Unrecht für Herrn Bürgel das sogar im
Parlament meine Damen meine Herren also
das originell die Zeit der Abstimmung so
meine Damen und Herren da sind wir
wieder live nachdem wir Hermann Gröhe
noch mal gehört haben und davor den
Bundesarbeitsminister zwischenzeitlich
haben wir auch schon den Bundeskanzler
gesehen der hier natürlich mit abstimmt
in dieser Debatte und die erste
Abstimmung ist hier gleich beendet wir
sehen und hören was Bundestags
Präsidentin Bars sagt Abstimmung zur
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Arbeit und Soziales auf Drucksache
4.360 fort unter Buchstabe b
empfiehlt der Ausschuss die Ablehnung
des Antrages der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache
3.943 mit dem Titel
aktivierende Grundsicherung statt
bedingungslosem Grundeinkommen
Einführung von Bürgerarbeit wer stimmt
für die Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen das ist die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen kann ich nicht erkennen
dann ist die Beschlussempfehlung so
angenommen und das bedeutet der Antrag
der AFD ist abgelehnt jetzt geht es
weiter mit drei Anträgen der
Linksfraktion die Linke auf Drucksache
3901 mit dem Titel sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
ausbauen
1150.000
Langzeitarbeitslose in Erwerbsarbeit
bringen so ist es richtig wer stimmt für
die Beschlussempfehlung das sind die
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP cdu/csu-fraktion und die
afd-fraktion Gegenstimmen sie Fraktion
DIE LINKE Enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht dann ist die
Beschlussempfehlung so angenommen und
auch hier gilt damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt das wird jetzt auch für die
beiden folgenden so sein deswegen spare
ich mir da ein zwischen Kommentar
Sanktionen abschaffen keine Kürzung am
Existenzminimum vornehmen wer stimmt für
die Beschlussempfehlung das sind die
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP cdu/csu und die afd-fraktion
Gegenprobe das Ablehnung bei der
Fraktion DIE LINKE Enthaltungen kann ich
nicht erkennen damit ist die
Beschlussempfehlung so angenommen
bis zum Vorliegen des Ergebnisses der
ersten namentlichen Abstimmung
unterbreche ich jetzt kurz die Sitzung
so und da müssen wir jetzt mal ein
bisschen spekulieren wie lange das wohl
dauern wird wie Abstimmung ist beendet
worden vor knapp nach ich sag mal drei
Minuten glaube ich dann hat er die
Bundestagspräsidentin ja hier bereits
zwei Anträge aufgerufen und abstimmen
lassen ein drei sogar ein dritter Antrag
aus den Rhein der Linksfraktion wird
nachher noch namentlich abgestimmt
werden es ist ein bisschen anders als
sonst hier heute aber wir versuchen mit
ihnen und mit der Bundestagspräsidentin
den Überblick zu behalten wie gesagt die
Sitzung ist jetzt unterbrochen weil die
Abstimmung von eben ausgezählt wird in
der es ja darum ging dass die
Unionsfraktion gefordert hatte dass nur
über einen Teil des bürgergeldgesetzes
abgestimmt wird nämlich über die
Regelsätze da ist die Union ja durchaus
dafür dass die Regelsätze dann aber für
ALG2 bzw Hartz IV im Anfang nächsten
Jahres steigen sollen aber die Koalition
macht wenn das nicht mit weil sie sagt
wir wollen über das ganze
bürgergeldgesetz abstimmen und nicht nur
über einzelne Punkte aus Sicht der
Koalition ist das ganze Jahr auch als
ein Gesamtwerk zu betrachten so
Sitzungsunterbrechung wir rechnen mit
gut zehn Minuten die es braucht um die
Stimmkarten auszuzählen wir bereiten uns
auch schon mal hier so ein bisschen auf
die mehrheitszahlen vor und wir nutzen
die Gelegenheit noch einmal auf weitere
debattenteile und Rednerinnen Redner
zurückzuschauen und sie zusammenzufassen
und das bedeutet dass wir Ihnen jetzt
noch mal zeigen Norbert Kleinwächter aus
der afd-fraktion unter vorbräter
Hasselmann die Vorsitzende der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und dann sind wir
in knapp zehn Minuten wieder live dabei
die Diskussion über eine dieser größten
Sozialreformen der letzten Jahrzehnte
nämlich das Bürgergeld ist eine sehr
wichtige und sie wird sehr kontrovers
geführt
lieber Hermann Gröhe ich habe sie hier
schon sehr oft reden gehört und ich
schätze sie sehr aber ihre Rede hat
gezeigt wie schwer es ihnen fällt die
Position von Friedrich Merz und Söder zu
vertreten
meine Damen und Herren wer keine
Argumente in der Sache hat verliert sich
im Verfahren und das wird dem Anliegen
das mit dem Bürgergeld verbunden wird
mit den vielen Menschen die davon
profitieren werden und die betroffen
sind in keiner Weise gerecht meine Damen
und Herren und
einstresst Friedrich Merz spitzt zwar
die Lippen öffentlich ja und er geht
sich in Vorurteilen gegenüber Menschen
die betroffen sind die von
Arbeitslosigkeit betroffen sind die arm
sind die in prekären
Beschäftigungsverhältnissen Leben schürt
sozial Neid ohne Ende eine solche
soziale Kälte in Krisenzeiten kaum zu
ertragen und verantwortungslos aber hier
im Parlament
hier in Parlament kneift er heute es ist
auch einfacher Interviews zu geben bei
denen keiner widersprechen kann meine
Damen und Herren weil heute wären wir
mit ihren Argumenten die sie öffentlich
führen mit Ihnen hier scharf ins Gericht
gegangen meine Damen und Herren
aber meine Damen und Herren es geht halt
um die
Lebenswirklichkeiten die sind in diesem
Land verschieden
und wie soll jemand der in einer ganz
anderen Lebenswirklichkeit lebt und sich
vielleicht überlegen muss ob er zur
Party mit dem Privatjet oder mit dem
Auto oder den Zug fliegt wie
soll sie Erziehenden Frau versetzen die
überlegen muss ob sie ein paar neue
Turnschuhe für das Kind kaufen kann oder
ob sie vielleicht heute einen Ausflug
machen kann in einer Eisdiele und mehr
als drei Kugeln Eis für ihre drei Kinder
drin sind da kann man auch nicht
erwarten dass man sich da reinversetzen
kann aber was ich von ihnen erwarte ist
Respekt
Respekt vor der Lebenslage eines jeden
Menschen und den haben sie nicht
das Bürgergeld ist viel mehr als eine
Regelsatzerhöhung und deshalb
beschließen wir es heute auch insgesamt
es ist eine Reform des Arbeitsmarktes es
wird Veränderungen bringen denn meine
Damen und Herren
darum und Weiterbildung es schafft
Perspektiven
für mit Ermittlung aber es geht nicht
mehr einfach nur um bloße Vermittlung
sondern um Qualifizierung und
Beschäftigung meine Damen und Herren es
geht nur darum des zweiten Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch und anderer Gesetze zur
Einführung eines bürgerge Bürgergeld ist
hierartikel 5 Nummer 1F Nummer 5 Nummer
15 Nummer 17 Nummer 18 die § 28a 134 SGB
Fortschreibung der regelbedarfsstufen
abgegebene Stimmkarten
683 mit Jahr haben gestimmt 681 mit Nein
hat niemand gestimmt es gab zwei
Enthaltungen
damit ist
sind die übrigen Teile des
Gesetzentwurfs angenommen und alle zu
wir kommen jetzt zur Schlussabstimmung
und damit zur nein
ach so Entschuldigung ja ich habe in
genau wir haben hier in der Übergabe ein
kleines Problem also wir setzen die
Abstimmung zu dem Entwurf eines
bürgergeldesgesetzes der Bundesregierung
fort und jetzt rufe ich auf die übrigen
Teile des Gesetzentwurfes in der
ausschussfassung diejenigen die den
übrigen Teilen des Gesetzentwurfes in
der ausschussfassung zustimmen wollen
bitte ich um das Handzeichen
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
vielen Dank damit sind die übrigen Teile
des Gesetzentwurfes angenommen bei
Zustimmung durch die koalitionsfraktion
cdu/csu und AFD haben dagegen gestimmt
die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat sich
enthalten damit sind jetzt alle Teile
des Gesetzentwurfes in zweiter Beratung
angenommen und wir kommen zur dritten
Beratung und Schlussabstimmung und damit
zur zweiten namentlichen Abstimmung sie
haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme
sie haben zur abgebung zur Abgabe ihrer
Stimme wiederum zehn Minuten Zeit ich
weiß jetzt schon darauf hin dass nach
der namentlichen Abstimmung während der
Auszählung des Ergebnisses die Sitzung
unterbrochen wird ich bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer die
vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen das ist
bereits der Fall
dann eröffne ich die namentliche
Abstimmung für nunmehr zehn Minuten
so das muss jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
nachsortieren für höhere Regelsätze also
alle da hat das im Vorfeld
unterschiedliche Aussagen gegeben und
diesen Punkt haben wir jetzt
abgeschlossen jetzt ist auch die zweite
Beratung abgeschlossen worden und jetzt
sind wir bei der Schlussabstimmung das
ist jetzt die denn
[Musik]
innerhalb der dritten Beratung und dann
wird das bürgergeldgesetz mit den
Stimmen der Koalition da wird es ja
nicht mehr eine so deutliche Mehrheit
oder eine so deutliches Jahr an Stimmen
geben für das bürgergeldgesetz sondern
da wird die eine Koalition ihre
Stimmen von 416 auf die Waagschale
bringen und dann muss man beobachten wie
sich die Linke beispielsweise dazu
verhält die ja durchaus einiges an
Kritik geäußert hat an diesem
bürgergeldgesetz und auch die Regelsätze
beispielsweise die Regelsatzerhöhung für
zu niedrig hält das bedeutet dass wir
jetzt hier wieder eine Unterbrechung
haben im Plenum für diese Abstimmung
dafür sind wieder knapp zehn Minuten
angesetzt und das gibt uns die
Gelegenheit noch mal zu schauen auf die
Debatte die wir gesehen haben und wir
machen es jetzt mit einem Ausschnitt aus
den Reden von Johannes Vogel und Dietmar
Bartsch
demokratie lebt von Wettstreit der
Argumente und die Opposition soll
deswegen natürlich die Koalition
kritisieren auch beim Bürgergeld nehmen
wir das Beispiel schon vermögen wir sind
der Meinung dass wenn zum Beispiel ein
selbstständiger durch einen
Schicksalsschlag auf die Grundsicherung
angewiesen ist dass er nicht als erstes
seine Altersvorsorge aufbrauchen soll
sie sehen das anders das ist ihr gutes
Recht darüber können wir hier streiten
es macht aber einen zentralen
Unterschied und das hat ist bei mir bei
dieser Debatte wirklich wichtig es macht
einen zentralen Unterschied ob man ein
alternatives politisches Urteil fällt
oder ob man alternative Fakten erfindet
und das haben wir hier in der
bürgerkette erlebt wir brauchen in der
Demokratie und das ist mir wirklich
ernst eine gemeinsame debattengrundlage
auf Basis von Fakten und
mir liegt hier der sitzungswöchentliche
Brief von Friedrich Merz aus der letzten
Sitzungswoche erste Lesung Bürgergeld
vor wo sich schwarz auf weiß Aussagen
finden die wir auch die letzten Tage
immer wieder in der Debatte gehört haben
mit dem Bürgergeld soll eine
sechs-monatige sanktionsfreie Karenzzeit
eingeführt werden sagen Sie Herr Merz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt nicht es
gibt keine sanktionsfreien Zeiten im
Bürgergeld sondern 80 Prozent der
Sanktionen werden auch den ersten sechs
Monaten weiter verhängt und danach sogar
das volle verfassungsrechtlich mögliche
Maße es ist kein Geheimnis Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Grünen nennen sich das
anders gewünscht das ist auch okay in
einer Demokratie aber wer etwas anderes
verbreitet der verbreitet Fake News und
das geht nicht in der demokratischen
Debatte
ein weiteres Zitat aus ihrem Brief die
Regelsätze sollen über die
Inflationsanpassung hinaus angehoben
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist schlicht nicht wahr es stimmt
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union an der rechnungsmethode der
Regelsätze ändert sich nichts zu Recht
gleichen wir die Inflation nicht mehr
anderthalb Jahre später aus das auch
eine Frage der Fairness und ja es ist
bekannt manche Kollegen und Kollegen aus
Koalitionsfraktionen von SPD und Grünen
hätten sich eine andere
Berechnungsmethode gewünscht aber das
steht nicht im Gesetzentwurf den wir
hier beraten und vollends schizophren
wird es wenn sie behaupten durch das
Bürgergeld lohne sich Arbeit in
Deutschland nicht mehr das ist erstens
in jedem einzelnen Fall falsch und
zweitens polemisieren sie damit gegen
eine Berechnungsmethode der Regelsätze
die eine CDU-Ministerin selber
eingeführt hat liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist doch schizophren und
unredlich richtig ist dass in unserem
Sozialstaat übrigens vorgegeben durch
Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts die Ansprüche
auf das Existenzminimum zum Beispiel bei
großen Familien so hoch sind dass ein
allein verlieren mit Mindestlohn das
nicht alleine durch sein Arbeitslohn
erwirtschaftet das ist richtig das ist
Ausdruck auch des sozialstaatsprinzips
das gibt unsere Verfassung vor das hat
aber genau nichts mit dem Bürgergeld zu
tun weil das heute schon so der Fall ist
und auch richtigerweise der Fall ist die
Frage ist also wie können wir dafür
sorgen dass sich Anstrengung zum
Beispiel auch bei diesen großen Familien
wenn Menschen arbeiten stärker lohnt
heute schon gibt es keinen Fall wo der
der arbeitet weniger hat als der der
nicht arbeitet und das ist auch richtig
durch Kindergeld Kinderzuschlag Wohngeld
all das was wir auch jetzt Anpassen an
die Inflation aber richtig ist es muss
sich stärker lohnen und dann muss man an
ein Thema ran was mir in der Tat sehr am
Herzen liegt nämlich das Thema
zuverdienstregeln und deshalb ist es
auch so absurd was die Union diese Woche
vorschlägt nämlich einfach nur die
Regelsätze zu erhöhen ohne durch die
Reform des Bürgergeldes auch für mehr
Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen zu sorgen das müssen
wir doch tun es muss sich mehr lohnen
Schritt für Schritt rauszuwachsen aus
der Grundsicherung und das schaffen wir
jetzt endlich das ist Kern der Bürger
der Reform liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und damit machen wir übrigens auch klar
dass junge Menschen diesem Land endlich
stärker Piloten des eigenen Lebens
werden heute lohnt sich nämlich auch
eine Ausbildung nicht das machen wir
anders das machen wir besser durchs
Bürgergeld heute werden zum Beispiel
wenn Annika die in einer
hartz-iv-familie groß wird im Minijob
arbeitet kann sie von 520 Euro 184
behalten wenn eische deren Eltern
finanziell auf eigenen Beinen stehen
denselben Minijob macht dann kann sie
520 Euro behalten junge Menschen
Verfahren schon in diesem Land heute vor
dem Bürgergeld am Anfang ihres Lebens
dass ich ihre Anstrengung nicht lohnt
das ist kein Unterschied macht wenn sie
arbeiten dass sie schlechtere Chancen
haben wegen weil ihre Eltern in
schwieriger Lagen sind das ist das
Gegenteil von Chancen Unabhängigkeit
unabhängig von der Herkunft und das
verbessern wir endlich
durch mehr Leistungsgerechtigkeit und
Aufstiegschancen
das macht nämlich vor allem was in den
Köpfen meine Fraktion hat diese Woche
drei junge Menschen nach Berlin
eingeladen Ferrat Sarah und Alex jeder
kann sich ihre Geschichten gerade seit
heute morgen auf Youtube anschauen sie
beschreiben sehr eindrücklich was das
was das in den Köpfen und den Herzen
macht wenn man schlechtere Chancen hat
wegen der Familie in die man geboren
wurde wir müssen uns doch nicht wundern
dass in unserem Land Chancen stärker von
der Herkunft abhängen wenn wir bereits
am Anfang des Lebens junge Menschen
Steine in den Weg legen das schaffen wir
endlich ab und darauf bin ich stolz denn
für diese Menschen kämpfen wir und
machen unser Sozialstaat fairer deshalb
stimmen wir heute für das Bürgergeld
vielen Dank
das was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
aktuell erleben das ist nicht anders zu
bezeichnen als ein Schmierentheater die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben angesichts der
Krise höhere Steuern für die
Topverdiener verlangt völlig zu Recht
und sie die Union lehnen das ab sie
spielen stattdessen Geringverdiener
gegen Arbeitslose aus das
Milliardenvermögen der Superreichen
schützen und das sogenannte
Schonvermögen von Menschen die
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet haben in Frage
stellen das ist unwürdig insbesondere
mit den Blick auf das C in ihrem Namen
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Britta Hasselmann die
Lebenswirklichkeit die
Lebenswirklichkeit ist dass die
Regelsätze jetzt 449 49 Euro betragen
ich erinnere daran dass im Januar die
Regelsätze um drei Euro erhöht worden
sind das war erbärmlich das war der
Staat der Koalition drei Euro so viel
kostet heute ein Stück Butter die
Inflation schon bei zehn Prozent sie
hätten die Regelsätze schon im Sommer
mindestens um diese 53 Euro anheben
müssen jetzt laufen die Taschen übrig
Fortschritt Koalition
in das eine schnarch-koalition immer zu
spät und immer zu wenig das ist die
Realität meine Damen und Herren bei den
Energiepreisen der gelungen viel zu spät
Erhöhung der Regelsätze Inflation
verpennt jetzt ist November sie mit
ihrer briesigkeit haben Friedrich Merz
erst ermöglicht dass es die Wahrheit
meine Damen und Herren wir erkennen ganz
klar an wir erkennen ganz klar an es
gibt Fortschritte Hubertus Heil hat das
an einem Beispiel eindringlich
geschildert Schüler Azubis studierende
können deutlich mehr behalten von ihren
Verdiensten das ist gut die zweijährige
Karenzzeit beim Wohnen sicherlich
positiv überhaupt keine Frage aber bei
allen Fortschritten bei allen
Fortschritten das Bürgergeld ist nicht
im
ansatzarmutsfest 53 Euro bleiben Armut
per Gesetz meine Damen und Herren
besorgt sich man die Inflation sind das
0,0 meine Damen und Herren liebe
Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokraten
was steht in eurem Programm die
Regelsätze im neuen Bürgergeld müssen zu
einem Leben in Würde ausreichen und zur
gesellschaftlichen Teilhabe befähigen
mit 53
Euro für ein Käse und was steht noch in
eurem Wahlprogramm das Bürgergeld muss
absichern dass eine kaputte
Waschmaschine und eine neue Winterjacke
nicht zu untragbaren Last werden das
leistet das Bürgergeld ausdrücklich
nicht das Bürgergeld ist zu wenig für
würde und auch zu wenig für eine neue
Waschmaschine meine Damen und Herren
Bürgergeld klingt gut aber real ist das
eben keine Abkehr von Hartz IV das
System bleibt erhalten in der Substanz
ist es hartz-
[Applaus]
von denen die meinen die Regelsätze
dürfen nicht armutsfest sein und das
Schonvermögen müsste möglichst gering
sein da wird immer dann das
Lohnabstandsgebot angeführt wie absurd
ist das denn wir haben kein Problem mit
zu hohen Regelsätzen wir haben aber
einen millionenfaches lohnproblem und
das wissen sind die Löhne schlicht zu
niedrig die Löhne müssen rauf und nicht
die Leistung politisch klein gerechnet
werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie immer auch
das Kind heißen mag am 1 Januar müssen
die Sätze steigen und wir brauchen
schleunigst dann eine realistische
Neuberechnung die den Mensch die die
Menschen wirklich tatsächlich vor Armut
schützt und ein Leben in Würde
garantiert und in der Zwischenzeit da
brauchen wir monatliche Zuschläge wie
das in unserem Antrag steht das wäre
eine Brücke meine Damen und Herren und
der Union kann ich nur zurufen hören sie
mit ihrer Blockade auf kein
Verschiebebahnhof zum ersten siebten die
Lage ist für die Betroffenen vielfach
dramatisch nehmen Sie bitte diese
Menschen in den Blick herzlichen Dank
Dietmar Bartsch und davor Johannes Vogel
außer Debatte zum Bürgergeld Gesetz und
wenn wir jetzt hier in den Plenarsaal
des Deutschen Bundestages gucken dann
sehen wir das ja relativ gut besetzt ist
das liegt an folgendem die Abstimmung
die Schlussabstimmung die namentliche
Schlussabstimmung zum bürgergeldgesetz
ist beendet und im Moment wird
ausgezählt solange ist die Sitzung hier
unterbrochenen unterbrochen wir rechnen
mit einem Ergebnis in ca 5,6 Minuten und
wir nutzen die Gelegenheit noch mal zwei
weitere Redner zu hören aus dieser
Debatte nämlich jetzt holtrine aus der
FDP-Fraktion und Kai Whittaker aus der
Unionsfraktion und wie gesagt den 5-6
Minuten werden wir dann hier das
Ergebnis der Schlussabstimmung haben
im Zentrum des Bürgergeld steht es nicht
wie immer wieder behauptet wird mehr
Lässigkeit im Zentrum des Bürgergelds
steht das Leistungsprinzip und
Berufseinstiegschancen durch
Qualifizierung also die nachhaltige
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt das ist
das Zentrum des Bürgergeldes und wenn
man ein Beispiel nennen müsste ein
einziges Beispiel an dem man das
festmacht dann sind es Auszubildende die
in einer Hartz iv-bedarfsgemeinschaft
aufwachsen wenn die aktuell dort 800
Euro Ausbildungsvergütung haben dann
bleiben ihm faktisch nur 240 Euro der
Rest wird angerechnet das
Hartz-IV-System was sie verteidigen was
sie nicht verändert haben sagt diesen
jungen Menschen eine Ausbildung und
Arbeit lohnt sich nicht
jetzt ist es so beim Bürgergeld von 800
Euro dürfen die 604 Euro behalten das
ist mehr als das 2,5-facher die
Botschaft des Sozialstaates ist klar es
lohnt sich zu arbeiten es lohnt sich
eine Ausbildung und wenn sie jetzt
kritisieren wie kann das denn sein dass
er überhaupt noch was angerechnet wird
das ist alles nur Aufstiegs Lyrik nein
das verändert bei jungen Menschen etwas
im Kopf es verändert die Botschaft und
wenn sie sagen wieso ist das zu wenig
wieso haben sie es in den letzten Jahren
nie angepasst wenn das doch eigentlich
eine Selbstverständlichkeit war weil es
ihn nicht um diese jungen Menschen geht
sondern es geht um eine Scheindebatte
und die Scheindebatte Herr Gröhe haben
wir erlebt sie haben gerade eben wieder
vorgeworfen den Brandbrief der
Personalräte der Brand lief der
Personalräte kam zum ersten
Gesetzesentwurf wir haben den
Gesetzesentwurf angepasst das so dass
beim zum ersten ersten nur die
Regelsätze in Kraft treten die
Karenzzeit und die Bagatellgrenze auf
Wunsch der BA die BA wünscht sich dass
diese Punkte zum ersten ersten Kraft
tritt alles andere wird nach hinten
verschoben die BA hat in der Anhörung
gesagt sie findet das total gut dass das
stattfindet sie hat gesagt sie braucht
diese Vorbereitungszeit und wünsche euch
dass der Bundesrat schnell zu einer
Entscheidung kommt weil eine bukadi in
schaden würde ihr Kollege Stracke ist
dann zur Presse gegangen hat gesagt die
BA würde dem Vorschlag der CDU
unterstützen nur die Regelsätze zu
erhöhen und sie wiederholen das jetzt
gerade sogar noch in der Debatte das
sind das ist die Form von Fake News die
sie immer wieder vortragen
und jeder dieser Fake News zu entkräften
dauert länger als in die Welt setzen und
deswegen möchte ich noch einen zweiten
Punkt bringen wo sie ja vielleicht jetzt
mal auch in der Sache was kritisieren
sie kritisieren das schon Vermögen das
sei viel zu viel
unser Ansicht nach ist wer kurzfristig
ins SGB 2 reinrutscht weil er
beispielsweise gar keinen Anspruch auf
Arbeitslosengeld 1 hat selbstständiger
als Beispiel der sollte nicht sofort
sein Haus verkaufen müssen seine
Altersvorsorge aufbrauchen müssen und
sein Erspartes dann sagt der Kollege
Whittaker genau dann sagt der Kollege
Whittaker ist doch jetzt schon das
Altersvorsorge ausgenommen wird ist doch
jetzt schon der Fall ich sehe auch
nicken in ihren rein gerade guckt man
aber genau ins Gesetz ist das nur die
staatlich geförderte Altersvorsorge es
ist nur Riester und rührup sobald sich
jemand entscheidet privat vorzusagen
vorvorzusorgen ist die nicht ausgenommen
und genau diese Feinheiten lassen sie
jedes Mal bei jedem Argument weg und
stürmen damit eine Debatte die es wo es
nicht um die Sache geht lassen Sie uns
um die Sache diskutieren wir sind für
private Altersvorsorge bei
Selbstständigen wir sind dafür dass sie
auch in Aktien investieren können und
das auch geschützt wird wenn sie kurz
wissen es geht um den Entwurf eines
zwölften als nächstes zu Änderungen des
zweiten Buches Sozialgesetzbuches
Sozialgesetzbuch und andere Gesetze der
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes auf den
Drucksachen
20426 und 2043 60 abgegeben wurden 679
Stimmkarten mit ja haben bestimmt 385
mit Nein haben gestimmt 261 es gab 33
Enthaltungen
wir setzen nun die Abstimmung zu der
Beschluss
damit angenommen das muss ich auch noch
sagen genau
er ist angenommen
das hat jetzt auch ein bisschen zu
Verwirrung geführt und die Abgeordneten
hätten durchaus gerne applaudiert aber
dadurch dass dieses Abstimmungsverfahren
heute etwas länger dauert ist das erst
so langsam ein gesickert ins Bewusstsein
also
bürgergeldgesetz hier angenommen in der
abschließenden Beratung und jetzt wird
noch mal aufgerufen ein Antrag der
Linken auch über den vietnamtlich
abgestimmt es geht um die Erhöhung der
Regelsätze noch mal
abendliche Abstimmung verlangt die
Abstimmung erfolgt wiederum in mehr
westlobby
sie haben jetzt zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme
nach Eröffnung der Abstimmung diesmal 30
Minuten Zeit und wir werden die Sitzung
nicht unterbrechen sie sollten also
nicht weglaufen ich bitte die
Schriftführerin Schriftführer die
vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen das ist
bereits der Fall dann eröffne ich die
dritte namentliche Abstimmung die Urnen
werden geschlossen um 11 Uhr
nichtsdestotrotz wird das gleiche im
Plenum weitergehen kathrin
gehring-eckardt hat eben diese letzte
Abstimmung die sich auf einen Antrag der
Linken bezieht Regelsätze spürbar
erhöhen heißt es da 200 Euro mehr gegen
Inflation und Armut dafür haben die
Abgeordneten jetzt etwas mehr Zeit und
deswegen ist das ein Verfahren dass wir
in den vergangenen Monaten auch schon
häufiger erlebt haben hier in dieser
Zeit wird die Debatte im Plenum
fortgesetzt werden und zwar mit einem
Antrag der
unionsfraktionen die den Titel der den
Titel trägt Straßen Blockierer und
Museums Randalierer härter bestrafen
Menschen und Kulturgüter vor radikalem
Protest schützen wie gesagt im der Lobby
läuft die Abstimmung zum Antrag der
Linksfraktion und was wir vielleicht
auch noch mal sagen sollten dass
bürgergeldgesetz ist hier angenommen
worden abschließend im Deutschen
Bundestag wird jetzt weiter verhandelt
mit dem Bundesrat denn die Union hat ja
nach wie vor Bedenken gegen eine ganze
Reihe von bestimmten in diesem Gesetz
und da werden sich mutmaßlich der
Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und
Bundesrat einigen müssen in nächster
Zeit der Wunsch der Koalition der Wunsch
der Ampel ist es nach wie vor dieses
Bürgergesetz mit all seinen Teilen und
mit all seinen Neuregelungen zum ersten
Januar des kommenden Jahres in Kraft
treten zu lassen da wird noch eine Menge
Arbeit und Kompromiss verhandelt werden
müssen damit das Ganze gelingen kann
aber jenseits der ganz großen Debatten
geht es möglicherweise auch schneller im
hintergeschlossenen Türen kommt man
möglicherweise dann doch noch zu einer
Einigung in diesem Punkt jetzt sind wir
angekommen beim Antrag der
Unionsfraktion den ich jedem eben schon
geschildert habe erster Rednerin wird
sein Andrea Lindholz stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der Unionsfraktion und wie
gesagt es geht um den Umgang mit
klimaprotestland die Straßen blockieren
und in Museen eindringen und mit Gemälde
bewerfen mit beispielsweise
Kartoffelbrei oder Tomatensaft die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin erahnt noch
mal jetzt doch hier langsam im
Plenarsaal zur Ruhe zu kommen das ist ja
auch eine Frage des Respekts gegenüber
den Rednerinnen und Redner hier im
Plenum Abstimmung muss auch sein aber
das kann man eigentlich alles in allem
durchaus koordiniert hinbekommen jetzt
Andrea Lindholz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Ende August
klebten sich zwei sogenannte
klimaaktivisten in Dresden an Rafael
Sixtinische Madonna aus dem Jahr 1512
Mitte Oktober bewarfen eine Frau und ein
Mann in Potsdam das Gemälde
getreideschober von Claude Monet aus dem
Jahr 1890 mit Kartoffelbrei am 31
Oktober standen in Berlin wieder einmal
rettungskräfte der Feuerwehr im Stau
weil sich Mitglieder einer Protestgruppe
auf der Stadtautobahn festgeklebt hatten
die Rettungskräfte waren auf dem Weg zu
einer Radfahrerin die nach einem Unfall
in Lebensgefahr schwebte und einige Tage
später leider verstarb unser Mitgefühl
gilt an dieser Stelle den Angehörigen
der 44-Jährigen insbesondere ihrer
Zwillingsschwester
wir wissen nicht ob das Leben der
Radlerin hätte gerettet werden können
aber laut dem Bericht der Berliner
Feuerwehr wäre zumindest eine
patientenschonende Rettung möglich
gewesen
das sind nur einige Beispiele für den
immer radikaleren Protest von Teilen der
klimaschutzbewegung in den vergangenen
Wochen und Monaten und ich will es
gleich zu Beginn in aller Klarheit sagen
das ist kein politischer Aktivismus mehr
das sind Straftaten
gezielt wird unser nationales Kulturgut
angegriffen und beschädigt gezielt
kleben sich Menschen auf Autobahnen und
an Verkehrsknotenpunkten auf der Straße
fest weil sie mit einer möglichst lang
anhaltenden Blockade von möglichst
vielen Menschen möglichst viel
Aufmerksamkeit erreichen wollen das hat
nichts mehr mit den einfachen
Sitzblockaden auf den Zufahrtsstraßen
nach Wackersdorf oder Gorleben zu tun
hier werden im Stau stehende Bürgerinnen
und Bürger instrumentalisiert zum Teil
wird Leib und Leben gefährdet oder wie
in diesem Fall eine nichtrettung
billigend in Kauf genommen seit Februar
wurden durch die Blockaden allein hier
in Berlin 18 Rettungsfahrzeuge im
Einsatz behindert und ich hoffe wir sind
uns hier alle einig das ist nicht
akzeptabel
und um es gerade auch in dieser um es
gerade in dieser Woche in der in Ägypten
die UN-Klimakonferenz stattfindet auch
ganz klar zu sagen der Schutz unserer
natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen ist eine
zentrale Aufgabe unserer Zeit vielleicht
ist sie sogar die zentrale Aufgabe und
es ist vollkommen in Ordnung für eine
andere Politik zu protestieren
Demonstrationen sie sind wichtig in
unserer Demokratie sie sind ein
wichtiges Instrument der politischen
Willensbildung viele von uns haben
selbst schon an einer Demonstration
teilgenommen das Demonstrationsrecht ist
von unserer Verfassung garantiert aber
es ist doch ganz klar weder der
Klimaschutz noch das Demonstrationsrecht
rechtfertigen Straftaten rechtfertigen
zunehmende Radikalisierung rechtfertigen
die Gefährdung von Menschen durch
Straßenblockaden die Behinderung von
Rettungskräften und die gezielte
Beschädigung historisch erkunstwerke
hier werden rote Linien überschritten
und unser Rechtsstaat er hat hierauf
bislang keine ausreichenden Antworten
gefunden es wurde vor allem Geldstrafen
verhängt aber mit Geldstrafen werden wir
diese zunehmende Radikalisierung in
diesem Bereich nicht aufhalten
Täter müssen den Unwert ihrer Taten
nicht nur finanziell sondern auch durch
den möglichen Freiheitsentzug spüren und
aus Sicht der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion sollen daher
Straßen blockiere die die Durchfahrt von
Polizei Feuerwehr und Rettungskräften
behindern oder billigend in Kauf nehmen
künftig statt einer Geldstrafe auch eine
mindestfreiheitsstrafe drohen und zu
diesem Zweck wollen wir den Strafrahmen
bei einem besonders schweren Fall der
Nötigung und bei einem gefährlichen
Eingriff in den Straßenverkehr auf
Freiheitsstrafe zwischen mindestens drei
Monaten und fünf Jahren anheben darunter
und auch für die Beschädigung und
Zerstörung von bedeutenden Kulturgütern
soll in Zukunft eine
mindestfreiheitsstrafe von drei Mon
statt wie bisher nur eine Geldstrafe
gelten
das ist ein Zeichen dass das Parlament
der Gesetzgeber setzen kann und wir sind
dafür hier auch ein Zeichen zu setzen
[Applaus]
ich möchte aber zum Schluss meine Rede
mit einem Appell an gerade die Menschen
beenden die diese inakzeptablen
Straftaten in Museen und auf der Straße
vornehmen und auch an die Menschen die
mit denen die sich radikalisieren
mitlaufen sei es wissentlich oder
unwissentlich
Klimaschutz ist wichtig aber er
rechtfertaten deswegen sage ich nutzen
Sie bitte die Instrumente der Demokratie
zerstören Sie nicht unser Kulturgut
gefährden sie nicht Leib und Leben
anderer Menschen blockieren sie keine
Rettungskräfte und Rettungsfahrzeuge
denn am Ende erreicht man mit solchen
Straftaten nur eines man schadet dem
wichtigen Ziel des Klimaschutzes selbst
und Klimaschutz muss im Vorrang stehen
und keine inakzeptablen Straftaten und
deshalb bitte ich auch unserem Antrag
zuzustimmen um ein Zeichen zu setzen
sagt Andrea Lindholz die
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion die eben diesen Antrag
den sie gerade begründet hat hier
eingebracht hat nächste Rednerin wird
Sonja eichwede sein sie ist
rechtspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsident
in der Demokratischen Fraktion die
Bewältigung der Klimakrise ist eines der
wichtig eine der wichtigsten
gesellschaftlichen Aufgaben unserer Zeit
und aus diesem Grund nimmt sie in
politischen Debatten und auch in
politischen Entscheidungen der letzten
Jahre sehr sehr großen Raum ein das
erklärte Ziel der AktivistInnen der
letzten Generation aber es die Erzeugung
von Aufmerksamkeit und die Störung dies
hat nichts mit Klimaschutz zu tun hier
muss unser Rechtsstaat mit allen zur
Verfügung stehenden Mitteln konsequent
handeln es gibt viele Wege sich in der
Demokratie und der Politik an der
politischen Meinungsbildung zu
beteiligen die Gefährdung der
öffentlichen Sicherheit und Ordnung und
die Begehung von Straftaten ist
selbstverständlich kein legitimes
prozessmittel das hat hier auch keiner
im Hause angezweifelt ein Fernziel
ein Fernseh wie der Klimaschutz
rechtfertigt sich nicht durch ein
konkretes zahlziel der Störung des
Straßenverkehrs oder eben der
Sachbeschädigung das vorweggenommen aber
kommen wir zum vorliegenden Antrag der
Unionsfraktion zu dem ich auch als
ehemalige Strafrichterin einige wichtige
Punkte sagen muss denn dieser zeugt von
einem populistischen Ruf nach
strafrechtlichen Verschärfungen der
weder den Ermittlungsbehörden hilft noch
weitere Straftaten verhindern könnte
erzeugt lediglich
erzeugt die lediglich von rechtlicher
und ebenso auch von tatsächlicher
Unkenntnis und viel schlimmer noch er
vermittelt den Eindruck dass unser
Rechtsstaat nicht handlungsfähig wäre
das ist falsch und es ist ebenso
fahrlässig
unser Straftat bietet zahlreiche
Möglichkeiten konsequent durchzugreifen
einige Tatbestände sprechen sie in ihrem
Antrag auch an in Betracht kommt die
Nötigung mit einer Freiheitsstrafe von
drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe der
gefährliche Eingriff in den
Straßenverkehr mit einer strafänderung
von einer Freiheitsstrafe bis zu fünf
Jahren oder Geldstrafe und die
gemeinschädliche Sachbeschädigung ebenso
mit einer Freiheitsstrafe von bis zu
drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe also
Freiheitsstrafen sind jedoch möglich
wenn sie tat und Schuld angemessen sind
und gerade bei Straßen blockieren ist
seit langem höchstrichterlich
entschieden dass durch die Verursachung
eines Staus aufgrund von physischer und
psychischen Straßenblockaden die dadurch
entstehen der Tatbestand der Nötigung
einschlägig ist und dass die
Beschmutzung von Gegenständen die das
Erscheinungsbild erheblich verändern
eine gemeinschaftliche Sachbeschädigung
sind diese Tatbestände sind anwendbar
hier wird auch zu ermittelt und die
lagen auch schon einige Urteile aus den
beschriebenen Taten vor das heißt der
Rechtsstaat handelt zu einem weiteren
Punkt ihres antragsbestimmung des
Strafmaßes und die Frage der Aussetzung
der Bewährung ist auch hier schon die
Handlung gegeben die wir haben denn das
erheblich rücksichtslose Vorgehen der
letzten Generation zum Beispiel ebenso
wie in anderen Fällen gegenüber anderen
Verkehrsteilnehmern wird strafschärfen
bereits jetzt
berücksichtigt ebenso ist die Begehung
einer Straftat unterlaufender Bewährung
eines der wichtigsten
Entscheidungskriterien gegen eine
weitere laufende Bewährung auch ich
musste als Strafrichterin solche
Entscheidungen treffen aber die
strafrichterinnen und Strafrichter
können doch am besten gucken ob noch
eine positive Sozialprognose vorliegt
oder nicht das ist nicht Sache der
Politik
all dies ist durch die erkennen in
Richter zu beurteilen ich fasse zusammen
der vorliegende Antrag aber zeugt von
einem mir unerklärlichen und gar
respektlosen Misstrauen gegenüber unsere
Justiz und gegenüber der Fähigkeit
unserer Richterinnen und Richter Tat und
Schuld angemessene Entscheidungen zu
treffen verehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Unionsfraktion dieses
Misstrauen hätte ich gerade von ihnen
nicht erwartet
aber aus welchem Grunde wollen Sie denn
sonst nur die Mindeststrafen
entsprechend hochsetzen abgesehen davon
ist schon lange wissenschaftlich belegt
das härtere Straftaten nicht abstrecken
und außerdem zwingt es mich bei ihrem
Antrag auch zu betonen das besonders
harte Strafen in einem Rechtsstaat nicht
gegen einen einzelnen Täter verhängt
werden können um quasi weitere
potenzielle Täter abzuschrecken Exempel
zu statuieren ist kein Merkmal eines
rechtsstaatlichen Systems sondern einen
Merkmal von autoritären Regime und so
eines haben wir gerade nicht mit hin ist
die angebliche Stärkung unseres
Rechtsstaats in Wahrheit eine Schwächung
ihres Rechtsstaats ich bitte Sie dieses
entsprechend zu überdenken die Höhe
einer Strafe bestimmt sich nach der Tat
und der Schuld des Täters im konkreten
Einzelfall die Unterstellung
entsprechende Tat nicht hart genug
verfolgt werden ist anmaßend
die Politik hat sich eben aus solchen
Entscheidungen rauszuhalten gerade der
strafzuständige Richter soll sich einen
sachgerechten Eindruck von dem
Angeklagten verschaffen und hinsichtlich
einer positiven oder negativen
Sozialprognose entscheiden und auch über
die Bewährung entscheiden aber sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Unionsfraktion verdutzt hat mich in
ihrem Antrag noch ein weiterer Punkt
denn die Forderung der Erhöhung des der
Mindeststrafe auf drei Monate
Freiheitsstrafe ist doch auch quasi in
rechtlichen Termini gesprochen ein
untauglicher Versuch in der Praxis würde
diese strafschärfung nicht keine Wirkung
zeigen und auch wohl nicht zu mehr
Freiheitsstrafen führen denn § 47 StGB
sagt doch richtigerweise das
Freiheitsstrafen unter sechs Monaten nur
in unerlässlichen Ausnahmefällen zu
verhängen sind und diese ausnahmebefälle
melden sich nach der konkreten Tat und
Persönlichkeit des Täters und gerade
nicht nach ganzen Fallgruppen mithin
mithin würde nach § 47 Absatz 2 StGB die
Mindeststrafe von drei Monaten bei einem
Tat auch zu einer Geldstrafe führen mein
Tipp an Sie werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Unionsfraktion für kommende
rechtspolitische Anträge ein Blick ins
Gesetz erleichtert die Rechtsfindung
abschließend bleiben drei Dinge zu sagen
erstens eine echte Stärkung unserer
Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Gerichte
erreichen wir nicht durch
Strafverschärfung sondern durch
Digitalisierung Modernisierung und eine
gute Ausstattung dafür setzt sich die
Ampel ein zweitens abgesehen von
ungerechtfertigten Taten der letzten
Generation erwartet die
Zivilgesellschaft und die junge
Generation gerade zu Recht dass wir
weiter effektiven Klimaschutz betreiben
wir als SPD-Fraktion wissen dass
effektiver Klimaschutz und soziale
Gerechtigkeit zusammengedacht werden
müssen und drittens
anstelle des Rufes nach höheren
Straftaten sollten Sie von der Union
lieber ihre politische Blockadehaltung
hinsichtlich der Frage von erneuerbaren
Energien überdenken und beispielsweise
in Bayern die 10h-regel kippen so können
wir im ganzen Land effektiven
Klimaschutz betreiben und gut
zusammenarbeiten vielen Dank
Sonja ich rede war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion wo sie rechtspolitische
Sprecherin ist und der Bundestag
diskutiert über Strafen für Straßen
Blockierer und sogenannte
museumsrandalierer das ist eine
Formulierung aus dem Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion der hier debattiert
wird und in dieser Debatte jetzt Thomas
Seitz der rechtspolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
die Extremisten der letzten Generation
üben Gewalt aus und gefährden das Leben
und die Sicherheit vieler Menschen und
nehmen die Beschädigung unersetzlicher
Kultur Güter in Kauf es geht um
gezielten Rechtsbruch nicht um zivilen
Ungehorsam die grüne RF ist mitten in
der Entstehung angesichts des
zunehmenden Extremismus braucht es
dringend ein Verbot dieser Organisation
hilft bei der Bekämpfung der
klimaextremisten aber davor liegende
Antrag definitiv nein den handwerklich
schlechter geht es kaum wenn schon
Populismus dann doch bitte richtig im
Einzelnen zur Forderung nach härteren
Bestrafungen
Ausschluss von kettenbewehrung das hört
sich hat zwar mit der Problematik nicht
wirklich zu tun hört sich aber nach law
and order an da ist es wohl zu viel
verlangt auf die Systematik einzugehen
die zwischen Straftaten bis sechs
Monaten bis zu einem Jahr und von über
einem Jahr differenziert unter Ziffer 2
wollen sie Paragraph 240 Nötigung um
weitere Regelbeispiele ergänzen um
Straßen Fragen zu Anden warum aber
Blockierer mit einer Mindeststrafe von
drei Monaten bedacht werden sollen
werden die bestehenden Regelbeispiele
ein Mindeststrafe von sechs Monaten
vorsehen das erschließt sich nicht
schlimmer ist dass ihnen offenbar nicht
bewusst ist dass in der Rechtspraxis
Mindeststrafe meist regelstrafe bedeutet
erst Täter würden also niemals mehr als
drei Monate bekommen die wegen § 47 StGB
die Kollegin hat es ausgeführt in 90
Tagessätze umgewandelt würden die
Tagessatzhöhe bei dieser hier
einschlägigen Klientel wird regelmäßig
mit zehn Euro bemessen werden also 900
Euro für eine Straßenblockade das ist
keine Abschreckung und vor allem dürfte
es für die Zahlung genügend Sponsoren
geben interessant ist sie vertreiben mit
der Idee dann gefährlichen Eingriff in
den Straßenverkehr die Eignung zur
Gefährdung ausreichen zu lassen und
gleichzeitig eine Mindeststrafe von drei
Monaten einzuführen sie stufen also die
Norm vom konkreten zum abstrakten
Gefährdungsdelikt herunter während der
schuldgehalt des Delikts abnimmt erhöhen
die Strafe zudem bringen sie das ganze
Gefüge der Paragraphen 315 bis 315c
durcheinander wenn sie aus vier
konkretende gefährdungsdelikten eines
herausgreifen und herabstufen und diese
Änderung bringt für Straßenblockaden
noch nicht einmal viel denn § 15b sitzt
eine verkehrsspezifische Gefahr voraus
die sich realisieren würde wenn
klimaverbrecher auf eine autobahnrennen
und dadurch eine massenkarombalage
verursachen tatsächlich aber wird im
städtischen Umfeld der Verkehr zum
Stillstand gebracht ohne dass es direkt
zu Unfällen kommt wenn sich ein Stau
bildet und es passieren dann
Folgeunfälle verwirklicht sich keine
verkehrsspezifische Gefahr sondern das
allgemeine Lebensrisiko das gleiche gilt
wenn ein Rettungsfahrzeug nicht durch
den Stau kommt wie letzte Woche in
Berlin
einschlägig wäre 315b nur dann wenn das
Hindernis ein ankommendes
Rettungsfahrzeug unmittelbar behindert
was in der Regel aber gerade nicht der
Fall ist
in Ziffer 4 wollen Sie 323c-absatz 2
verschärfen nur die Vorschrift passt in
den meisten Fällen überhaupt nicht die
Reihenfolge muss da lauten Unglück
rettungswilliger Behinderung wenn man
sich aber an der Straße festklebt und es
kommt erst später zu einem Unglück ist
die Behinderung ein reiner Flex keine
taugliche taghandlung genauso wenig
durchdacht ist die Überlegung die
übereinschädliche Sachbeschädigung zu
verschärfen denn wir haben gerade
gelernt Mindeststrafe drei Monate heißt
praktisch 900 Euro Geldstrafe was wäre
also zielführend eine Blockade von
Verkehrswegen bedeutet für alle die auf
ein ungestörten Verkehrsweg angewiesen
sind eine Risikoerhöhung es geht um
einen schnellen Transport ins
Krankenhaus oder das rechtzeitige
Eintreffen der Feuerwehr oder Raum zu
verhindern dass die Kinder irgendwo
hilflos vor verschlossener Türe stehen
das oftmals um Leben oder Tod geht muss
das Risiko dass die Frage der Kausalität
meist nicht mehr zu klären sein wird den
Störern auferlegt werden ohne wenn nun
aber es führt kein weg einen speziellen
Tatbestand vorbei der vor dieser
Risikoerhöhung schützt und eigentlich
müssten wir über einen
verbrechensaatbestand nachdenken um
wirklich abzuschrecken und auch um zu
verhindern dass das Verfahren wegen
geringer Schuld oder gegen Geldauflage
einfach eingestellt wird
für Vandalismus in Museen gilt das
Gleiche wir sind gesprächsbereit vielen
Dank
Thomas Seitz aus der afd-fraktion
spricht von einer grünen RAF er nimmt
damit sinngemäß eine Formulierung des
csu-landesgruppenvorsitzenden Alexander
Dobrindt der dieser Tage bei Twitter von
einer Klima RAF gesprochen hat für alle
die Jünger sind die RAF die rote
armee-fraktion war eine
linksextremistische terroristische
Vereinigung die für mindestens 33
gezielte Morde verantwortlich war unter
anderem anführungskräften aus Politik
und Wirtschaft Irene Mia Alices Bündnis
90 die Grünen erste parlamentarische
Geschäftsführerin völlig unabhängig
davon ob der Grund für den
protestberechtigt sein mag oder nicht
darüber haben wir in einer Demokratie
sowieso nicht zu befinden Protest darf
und soll kreativ sein und ja Protest
darf auch stören aber er findet seine
Grenzen wo Leib und Leben von Menschen
gefährdet werden oder die Schwelle zu
Straftaten überschritten wird meine
Damen und Herren und
es wird auch nicht besser wenn Proteste
unter dem Label Klimaschutz laufen ganz
im Gegenteil die letzte Generation
erweist dem Klimaschutz einen
Bärendienst und streut all denen Sand
ins Getriebe die sich ernsthaft und
aufrichtig für eine wirksame
Klimaschutzpolitik einsetzen denn
denn das Prinzip dass der Zweck die
Mittel heiligt können wir im Rechtsstaat
nicht akzeptieren und darüber hinaus
sind diese gefährlichen Aktionen auch
noch mit dem Blick auch noch mit Blick
auf den vermeintlichen Zweck völlig
nutzlos denn jetzt reden ja wieder alle
nur über Protestformen über das was geht
was nicht geht über Straßenblockaden
über Tomatensuppe auf Gemälden aber eben
nicht über die massiven Folgen der
Klimakrise selbst jetzt während der Korb
27 überlagern die Debatten um den
Protest die wichtigen Diskussionen und
Entscheidungen die global gegen diese
existenzielle Bedrohung der Klimakrise
stattfinden müssen und die gefährlichen
Aktionen der sogenannten letzten
Generation sind daher in diesem Sinne
klimapolitisch kontraproduktiv sie sind
rechtsstaatlich hochproblematisch und
damit vollkommen inakzeptabel
aber jetzt komme ich
jetzt komme ich zum Antrag der Union
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
das was sie hier machen ist mindestens
genauso hart am Thema vorbei wie die
Proteste für die Sie jetzt eine
Strafverschärfung fordern sie haben ja
geradezu nur nach einer Gelegenheit
gesucht von ihrem eigenen Scheitern in
der Klimapolitik ablenken zu können
indem sie jetzt nicht nur die letzte
Generation sondern gleich die gesamte
klimaschutzbewegung diffamieren sowie
Herr Dobrindt im Konzert mit Herrn Seitz
wie wir gerade alle hören konnten von
einer Klima RAF spricht damit Herr
Dobrindt ja stellen Sie nicht nur alle
in den Senkel die sich ernsthaft und
gewaltfrei für mehr Klimaschutz
einsetzen sondern sie stellen die Opfer
von vorsätzlichem Mord und brutalem
Terrorismus in eine Reihe mit
Autofahrern die im Stau stehen das kann
doch nicht ihr Ernst sein Herr Dobrindt
das ist eine unerträgliche Verharmlosung
des Terrors der RAF und eine
Verunglimpfung der Opfer unter
Hinterbliebenen dafür sollten Sie sich
in Grund und Boden schämen
gerade des Kollegen meinen Gedanken
gerne zu Ende führen und dabei wo wir
gerade bei Gedanken sind ja wo wir
gerade bei Gedanken sind
sie denken ja noch nicht
einmal was sie hier im Kern fordern ja
denn was heißt denn das was sie in ihrem
Antrag schreiben für die Traktoren Demos
von Landwirten ja die zweifellos auch
eine Sicherheitsgefährdung darstellen
sollen die jetzt etwa alle in den Knast
wenn Sie den Verkehr der halben Republik
lahmlegen nein da sind sie ganz
solidarisch und pflegen ihre doppelten
Standards im Sinne einer so wie es
gerade passt Partei aber dabei legen sie
selber die Axt an den Rechtsstaat den
sie angeblich schützen wollen und
deswegen sage ich Ihnen deswegen sage
ich Ihnen ganz klar Proteste die Leib
und Leben von Menschen gefährden sind
inakzeptabel und zwar völlig unabhängig
vom Zweck der Rechtsstaat hat alles
Nötige um effektiv dagegen vorzugehen
ihre peinlichen
strafverschärfungsförderung brauchen wir
da nicht wenn sie was kluges fordern
wollen machen Sie mal mehr Vorschläge
für ein verbesserten Klimaschutz oder
für eine kluge Verkehrspolitik damit
könnten sie der Gesellschaft auch etwas
zurückgeben was sie letzten 16 Jahre
nicht hinbekommen haben vielen Dank
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Alexander Dobrindt verzichtet auf eine
kurze Intervention er hatte ja um eine
wollte eine Zwischenfrage stellen in der
Rede von Irene miavic sein wird
das jetzt bitte tun und zu einer
Kurzintervention gebe ich das Wort dem
Kollegen doch haben wir nicht gesehen
jetzt spricht er doch
[Applaus]
liebe Frau Kollegin michalic wenn sie
mich schon zitieren wollen was vom
Grundsatz her ja sinnvoll sein kann dann
versuchen Sie es doch aber auch richtig
zu machen wörtliches Zitat die
Entstehung einer Klima RAF muss
verhindert werden liebe Frau Kollegin
ist Ihnen bekannt die Einschätzung von
Bettina Röhl der Tochter von Ulrike
meinhoff die wörtlich gesagt hat die
letzte Generation ist schon auf der
Ziellinie zur RAF weiter sind sie mit
mir der Meinung dass die Entstehung
einer Klima RAF verhindert werden muss
ja oder nein oder was muss passieren
damit sie sich diese Einschätzung
anschließen
[Applaus]
Präsidentin Herr Dobrindt
hier eins Zusammenhang zu konstruieren
ja zwischen den abscheulichen Taten der
RAF des Terrorismus ja und das was wir
hier auf der Straßen erleben ist schon
ungeheuerlich ja ist ungeheuerlich und
Sie können es nicht weg relativieren sie
können es jetzt auch hier mit dem was
hier gerade gesagt haben nicht weg
relativieren diesen Zusammenhang diesen
Zusammenhang haben sie hergestellt und
dann müssen sie sich auch damit
auseinandersetzen dass das im Kern eine
Verunglimpfung und der Opfer des
Terrorismus ist und eine Verharmlosung
des brutalen Terrorismus den die RAF
über dieses Land gebracht hat und wenn
sie sich schon mit der Vergangenheit
beschäftigen und auch Zeitzeugen hier
zitieren ja dann können sich ja
vielleicht mal mit den Familien der
Opfer der RAF beschäftigen und mal
fragen was die davon halten wenn Sie die
Opfer wenn Sie zum Beispiel Familie
Herrhausen können sie ja mal fragen ja
wenn Sie die Opfer der RAF in eine Reihe
stellen mit Leuten die im Straßenverkehr
blockiert werden ja oder die auf andere
Art und Weise beeinträchtigt werden
durch die Proteste die ja gerade
stattfinden und da können sie ja mal
fragen wie die das Finden ich glaube die
Antwort darauf zu kennen Herr Dobrindt
und deswegen bleibe ich dabei was ich
gerade gesagt habe sie können eine
solche unerträgliche Relativierung von
Terrorismus hier im Hohen Haus nicht
unwidersprochen vornehmen und deswegen
bleibe ich bei dem was ich gerade
ich komme noch mal zurück zum
Tagesordnungspunkt 10b die Abstimmung
ist jetzt vorbei und ich frage es noch
ein Mitglied des Hauses anwesend dass
die Stimme nicht abgeben konnte das ist
nicht der Fall dann schließe ich die
Abstimmung und bitte die Schriftführerin
und Schriftführer mit der Auszählung zu
beginnen das Ergebnis wird Ihnen später
bekannt gegeben und jetzt gebe ich das
Wort der Kollegin Clara Bünger für die
Fraktion Die Linke und ich sage Ihnen
meine Damen und Herren nochmal fix um
welchen Antrag es hier ging nämlich dem
der linksfraktionen mit dem Titel
Regelsätze spürbar Erhöhung 200 Euro
mehr gegen Inflation und Armut und jetzt
wie von der Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
schon angekündigt Clara Bünger
rechtspolitische Sprecherin der
Linksfraktion
einfach ein Landtagsabgeordneter der CDU
von Öko-Terroristen Sie Herr Dobrindt
warnten vor einer klimarafe so wie es
Frau mechalisch auch gerade gesagt haben
und durch ihre Ausführung wurde ihre
Aussage einfach auch nicht besser und
der hessische
Justizminister fabulierte über
terroranklagen gegen klimaaktivisten
damit vergleichen Sie Personen die sich
für den Erhalt der menschlichen
Lebensgrundlage einsetzen mit
Verbrechern die Bomben bauen und aus
Verachtung von menschlichen Leben
Anschläge verüben wenn sie das wirklich
ernst meinten sollten Sie sich für diese
Vergleiche schämen
in ihrem Antrag geben Sie vor es ginge
ihnen um den Schutz des Lebens und der
körperlichen Unversehrtheit aber die
oben genannten Aussagen die ich gemacht
habe machen deutlich worum es ihnen
eigentlich geht die größtmöglichste
Kriminalisierung politischer
Meinungsäußerung die nicht mit ihren
eigenen übereinstimmen sie wollen
Menschen
politisch links stehen das ist kein
demokratischer Vorschlag das sind
autoritäre Anwandlungen die unsere
Debattenkultur und unsere Demokratie
ernsthaft gefährden
und ich glaube ja sie haben einfach
Angst nach 16 Jahren in der Regierung
haben sie Angst vor Bedeutungsverlust
weil sie merken dass sie keine Antworten
auf die drängenden Probleme unserer
Gesellschaft haben aber diesen Gefühl
der Unsicherheit begegnet man doch nicht
mit dem Strafrecht sondern mit eigenen
tragfähigen politischen Ideen
und auch wir haben ja ihren Antrag
gelesen wenn da mittlerweile keine
ohnehin rechtswidrige Präventivhaft mehr
drin ist und sie das nicht mehr fordern
läuft ist juristisch betrachtet auf
quatschjora hinaus was sie da
formulieren so wollen sie § 240 Absatz 4
StGB um Regelbeispiele erweitern die
Teilnahme an Sitzblockaden im
Straßenverkehr soll ein besonders
schwerer Fall der Nötigung werden aber
Sitzblockaden zur politischen
Meinungsäußerung fallen nach ständiger
Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts die sehr
ausdifferenziert ist in den
Schutzbereich des Versammlungsrechts aus
Artikel 8
und wenn keine verwerfliche Nötigung
vorliegt müssen wir über eine besondere
Schwere bei der straftemessung gar nicht
reden Frau Bünger möchten Sie die
Zwischenfrage von Frau Lindholz zulassen
ich möchte jetzt erstmal meine Gedanken
zu Ende bringen aber kommen wir zurück
zum Grund der Proteste Luisa Neubauer
sagte richtigerweise dass die Kritik an
den Aktionsformen der letzten Generation
nichts an der bestehenden
Klimakatastrophe ändert das sämtliche
Klimaziele die ohnehin viel zu
unambitioniert waren
nicht eingehalten werden wenn sie sich
nicht bald grundlegend etwas ändert
werden große Teile der Erde unbewohnbar
zig Millionen Menschen werden ihre
Lebensgrundlage verlieren wie wir es
dieses Jahr auch schon in Pakistan
gesehen haben sie werden sterben oder
zur Flucht getrieben statt das in den
Mittelpunkt ihres politischen Handels zu
stellen geht aber auch die Koalition auf
ihre Droge werden ein und die
Innenministerin unterstellt das
vorsätzlich Rettungswege versperrt
wurden ich kenne keine klimaaktivistin
die sich mit Vorsatz der versperrung von
Rettungswegen mit UHU auf die Straße
geklebt hat im Gegenteil wir haben wir
Montag am Montag gesehen wie in Leipzig
Menschen die eine Straßenblockade
gemacht haben sofort Platz gemacht haben
als die Feuerwehr durch müsste so muss
das laufen
und der Tod der Radfahrerin ist wirklich
sehr tragisch ich denke wir alle müssen
verhindern dass Menschen im
Straßenverkehr sterben die letzte
Generation muss das tun und wir müssen
aber auch alle dafür sorgen und dann
müssen wir auch darüber diskutieren wie
wir solidarisch miteinander umgehen
rettungsgassen bilden nicht in der
zweiten Reihe parken denn 80 Prozent der
Fälle werden keine rettungsgassen
gebildet daran müssen wir etwas ändern
alle klimaproteste in Frage zu stellen
sollte die Bundesregierung endlich
Maßnahmen ergreifen um den Klimawandel
zu stoppen vielen Dank
Clara Bünger war das rechtspolitische
Sprecherin der Linksfraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag wir sind nach wie
vor in der Debatte über einen Antrag der
Unionsfraktion zu Strafen für Straßen
Blockierer und Museums Randalierer man
muss sagen für härtere Strafen um genau
zu sein jetzt kommt eine
Kurzintervention von Andrea Lindholz aus
Kolleg
in Zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen sie
haben in ihrer Rede zum einen von den
Gefühlen der Opfer gesprochen und zum
anderen haben Sie die klimaaktivisten
gerechtfertigt
haben Sie eigentlich das Interview der
Zwillingsschwester der Verstorbenen
Radfahrerin im Spiegel zur Kenntnis
genommen und wie stehen Sie zu dem was
die Schwester gesagt hat und was ich
Ihnen jetzt auch vorhalte über den Grund
warum sie die Öffentlichkeit sucht hat
sie gesagt weil ich in der
Berichterstattung las wie ignorant
einige klimaaktivisten den Tod von
Menschen in Kauf nehmen wie stehen Sie
zu dieser Einschätzung
Frau Bünger bitte
der Radfahrerin natürlich das tiefe
Mitgefühl mitteilen und da stehen wir
auch als Linksfraktion dafür ich finde
es wirklich ungeheuerlich wie sie das
Schicksal dieser Radfahrerin hier für
ihre politischen Zwecke
instrumentalisieren
es ist erschüttert mich ernsthaft dass
sie auch auch das so in die
Öffentlichkeit ziehen ich weiß nicht mal
ob die Familie der Radfahrerin der
Radfahrerin überhaupt selber das so
befürworten würde ich denke in diesem
Zusammenhang haben wir alle sehr viel
unterschiedliche Berichterstattungen
gesehen mit unterschiedlichen
Positionierungen wie zum Beispiel dass
die Ärztin gesagt hat dass die
Radfahrerin nicht hätte gerettet werden
können und es gibt dazu unterschiedliche
Berichte und die sind auch sehr
ausdifferenziert und was sie hier machen
ist das populistisch für ihre eigene
politischen Zwecke Zweck zu entfremden
und das halte ich für gefährlich und
auch nicht richtig und angemessen
Clara Bünger noch mal mit einer
wiederung auf eine kurze Intervention
von Andrea Lindholz und jetzt würde ich
jetzt noch einmal zurückkommen zum
Tagesordnungspunkt von vorhin weil wir
das Ergebnis der namentlichen Abstimmung
vorliegen haben zu dem Antrag der
Abgeordneten tatti herrschel birkwald
und weitere Abgeordneter Fraktion DIE
LINKE Regelsätze spürbar erhöhen 200
Euro mehr gegen Inflation und Armut auf
den Drucksachen
2040 53 und 2043 60 und die
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Arbeit und Soziales wurden abgegeben 679
Stimmkarten mit ja haben bestimmt 643
mit 935 es gab eine Enthaltung mit hin
ist die Beschlussempfehlung angenommen
und jetzt kommen wir zurück zu unserer
Debatte und ich gebe jetzt das Wort an
Konstantin Kuhle für die FDP und damit
haben wir den ganzen komplexen
Bürgergeld Gesetz von heute morgen
Tagesordnungspunkt 10 ist das gewesen
endgültig abgeschlossen der Antrag der
AFD also abgelehnt und wir kommen zurück
zur Debatte
zu Straßen blockieren und Museums
Randalierern Konstantin Kuhle für die
FDP-Fraktion dass ich mehr Menschen für
das Thema Klimaschutz interessieren und
engagieren die friedlichen Proteste etwa
von Fridays for future haben dazu
geführt dass ich bis in die Mitte der
Gesellschaft hinein mehr Menschen selbst
kritisch die Frage stellen tun wir als
Gesellschaft tun wir als Staat als
Gemeinwesen eigentlich genug für den
Klimaschutz und diese Geschichte diese
Errungenschaft ist etwas das friedliche
klimaproteste erreicht haben und dafür
gilt ihnen Respekt und Anerkennung meine
Damen und Herren was wir aber in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten an
Radikalisierung und an Militanz bei den
klimaprotesten erleben das bewirkt genau
das Gegenteil denn das führt dazu dass
die gesellschaftliche Mitte sich
abwendet vom Thema des Klimaschutzes die
sogenannte letzte Generation sie macht
aus dem Thema Klimaschutz ein radikales
Nischenthema und genau diese Gefahr
führt dazu dass wir weniger Klimaschutz
in der Gesellschaft haben und dass wir
weniger politische Debatten über dieses
wichtige Thema haben oder man könnte
auch sagen die Aktivisten und Aktivisten
der sogenannten letzten Generationen
reißen mit dem Hintern ein was Luisa
Neubauer und Greta thünberg mühsam
aufgebaut haben
und wenn wir uns einmal mit der Attitüde
mit der Haltung dieser Demonstranten
auseinandersetzen dann ist diese Haltung
nicht nur im Kern antidemokratisch weil
es darum geht keinen Widerspruch keine
andere Meinung zuzulassen sie ist auch
totalitär sie ist autoritär und sie ist
von einer Herablassung geprägt die
kontraproduktiv ist denn die Leute die
da blockiert werden die Leute die nicht
zur Arbeit kommen die müsste man
eigentlich davon überzeugen das
Klimaschutz eine wichtige Sache ist aber
glaubt ihr denn im Ernst dass ein
Polizist der sich da morgens um 7 Uhr
darum kümmern muss dass euch nichts
passiert wenn ihr euch festklebt dass
eine Mitarbeiterin im ambulanten
Pflegedienst die ab 7 Uhr ab 6 Uhr die
älteren Leute pflegen will dass
diejenigen die ihren ersten Termin als
Handwerker haben um 6 Uhr um 7 Uhr
morgens dass die für mehr Klimaschutz
sind bei solchen Aktionen das Gegenteil
wird eintreten und wenn ich dann höre
das Aktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation ihr Studium abbrechen ihre
Ausbildung abbrechen aus Angst vor dem
Thema Klimaschutz das ist nichts anderes
als eine unerträgliche Hybris die dazu
führt dass man sich die Frage stellen
muss wer kann sich sowas eigentlich
erlauben die Menschen die ich gerade
aufgezählt habe mit einem einfachen
Einkommen mit einem durchschnittlichen
Einkommen jedenfalls nicht und deswegen
ist all das etwas was aufhören muss und
wo sich auch die gesamte Klimabewegung
radikal von abgrenzen muss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und jetzt sind wir beim Schlafen
und jetzt sind wir beim Strafrecht jetzt
sind wir bei einem Mittel dass das
schärfste Schwert ein Instrument dass
das ultima ratio Instrument des
Rechtsstaats ist und da muss man ganz
klar sagen hängt die Union leider der
Haltung an dass man jedes
gesellschaftliche Problem jedes neue
Phänomen automatisch mit schärferem
Strafrecht lösen kann die Realität ist
aber ganz anders das geltende Recht
sieht anders als sie hier gesagt haben
doch für die einfache Sachbeschädigung
und für die einfache Nötigung auch eine
Freiheitsstrafe vor das haben sie hier
falsch dargestellt das geltende Recht
sieht auch vor dass Straßenblockaden
eine strafbare Nötigung sein können und
zwar auch wenn die sich auf die
Versammlungsfreiheit berufen wenn
nämlich der Konnex zwischen denjenigen
die ich blockiere und dem Thema über das
ich spreche für das ich demonstriere
nicht hinreichend gegeben ist dann ist
das eine strafbare Nötigung und dann
müssen die Leute auch verurteilt werden
und zwar schnell liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es ist außerdem es ist außerdem
geltendes Recht dass wir ein
beschleunigtes Verfahren haben bringen
wir doch mal das beschleunigte Verfahren
zum Einsatz und brauchen nicht Monate
oder Jahre bis solche Leute mal
verurteilt werden es ist außerdem
geltendes Recht dass jemand der eine
Sache kaputt macht oder der eine solche
Blockade macht für die Schäden die da
entstehen haften muss machen wir die
doch zivilrechtlich verantwortlich den
muss eine Rechnung geschickt werden
dafür dass dort Leute nicht zur Arbeit
kommen dass dort Termine nicht
wahrgenommen werden können das
Gegenstände in Museen kaputt gehen die
müssen dafür blechen damit sie merken
dass man sowas nicht macht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das
geltende Recht
und das geltende Recht sieht auch vor
dass Richterinnen und Richter über die
Strafbarkeit entscheiden und nicht wir
hier im Deutschen Bundestag und deswegen
lehnen wir Ihren Antrag ab und werden
gerne weiter daran mitwirken genau uns
anzuschauen welche Strafurteile da in
den nächsten Wochen in den nächsten
Monaten ausgeurteilt werden lassen Sie
mich abschließend sagen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde es
gut wenn wir hier im Bundestag über das
Thema Klimaschutz sprechen würden ich
finde es gut dass wir darüber reden wenn
wir darüber reden ob das Wind an Land
gesetzt ob der Kohleausstieg ob all die
guten Sachen die wir schon gemacht haben